from the docket here at 10 o'clock uh a
number of bills just just four or three
right modern math here
um I I the first one I want to look at
is we have some technical support here
today on the aeronautical Bill Institute
and that's going to be 260 SB 216. let
me explain what we're doing here
we
know
civics
that's it
already I don't have that and they don't
give me anything here okay SB 24 is what
we'll take up first here and we're going
to go into the executive session rather
than posting another hearing we've
oftentimes taken technical support
during exec sessions if we had questions
and so what I want to do is open up SB
24 and there were some technical
questions which were asked when we were
in this previously
uh uh discussing this on was it April
11th yeah April 11th
time flies when we're having fun doesn't
it and and uh the technical questions
were more aligned with uh what's been
done with a higher education uh
commission which looks at uh
post-secondary education and and uh some
questions regarding the aeronautical
institution is stealth so with that we
have invited today folks from that and
um
in pencil right here I know we have
director Appleby here uh then we have
the president of neaai uh Triant Flores
yes and UNH Dean
um
of online which is uh Scott Stanley
Scott's here and we also have uh Don
Burks from the uh higher ed commission
who is are you the chair of it Don
thumbert thank you so and who else is
here to help you in this process because
I'm going to just invite all four up at
the same time if we could do that so
that pardon me just four just four so
why don't we have all four come up to
the the mics right here and we need to
get this technical support and better
understanding
um what has transpired and
Don maybe if you could uh or Steve do
you have a process in which you want to
go through on this or should we let Don
who's chairing that you'll okay so Dr
Appleby will go first and then we'll
just
thank you very much welcome good morning
everyone uh thank you very much for your
time this morning Steve Appleby director
of educator support and higher education
at the Department of Education one of my
roles is to support the higher education
commission it's one of the programs that
I oversee at the department from a
process standpoint the process for
approving a new institution begins with
the Department performing a review team
of which in this case
Dean Stanley was uh the the chair of
that team and we asked the prospective
institution to submit
um well there's a series of documents
that line up to the standards in our
administrative rules and those standards
track very closely to Nichi standards
the regional accreditor for for New
England and uh
as Dean Stanley leads the review team
they look at those standards they
interview faculty they interview of
course the administration they look at
finances they look at curriculum
facilities if that applies Library all
those types of things you would expect
from a college and the review team then
makes recommendations to both the
prospective institution as well as to
the commission
in this instance the review team made a
number of recommendations the
prospective College implemented those
recommendations and reported back to the
review team at that point the review
team was satisfied and recommended
next up the prospective College
presented to the commission and the
commission looked at the report
generated by the review team and voted
unanimously to approve uh the
institution so there were very few
questions in this case the
administration is known shall we say Dr
Flores was Dean Dean Daniel Webster
College
dean of Aviation at Daniel Webster
College he's also a commercial pilot and
very involved in this industry they
presented quite a bit of information to
support the need for this degree in the
marketplace which the commission was
pleased to see so that's kind of the
overall process it took
probably a little over a year from start
to finish of course it took them a lot
longer right but it took from a
commission standpoint from the first
presentation through the review and then
through the final vote took a little
over a year
so
questions about the question questions
for
theoe
yes reps and Ford when the program thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking a
question when the program was at Daniel
Webster it was a full component of that
area
avionics and other programs at the
college right
I can speak to that there was no
avionics uh Daniel Webster there were
there were three programs three
undergraduate programs one was flight
operations the other one was Aviation
management and the third one was air
traffic management uh there was an
airframe and power plant program as it's
called which contains avionics which is
done at Nashua Community College on all
of those programs were accredited and
fully approved as at Daniel Webster that
were simply brought forward uh there
were they have not been brought forward
no uh Daniel Webster seized operations
okay and some parts of the school were
acquired by Southern New Hampshire
University some some programs uh one of
them was actually Aviation however
Southern New Hampshire University did
not continue on on that program
and it was at that time that when we saw
how things were moving forward me and
the other three Deans from Daniel
Webster are all of whom have had left
um the school some of them prior to the
uh closure of the school uh and we
decided to to uh restart uh the aviation
programs in the state of New Hampshire
uh for for two different reasons uh one
is because as
executive director Appleby mentioned the
industry right now or the need as far as
the industry is concerned it's very
robust both in the United States and
globally and and secondly because we
actually wanted to maintain that history
the rich history of an institution and
we acquired the name New England
aeronautical Institute which is really
how things got started for Daniel
Webster before there was Daniel Webster
there was New England aeronautical
Institute so that was a name that we
actually took over and we are rebuilding
this we're trying to rebuild this Rich
history based on that original name it's
been around since 1965.
thank you and if I may uh if I just want
one more piece of information in terms
of uh those those other colleagues
um uh one of them is Tom teller who is
at MIT Lincoln lab he went to as a as a
chief research scientist at MIT Lincoln
lab after he left Daniel Webster the
other one is Nick bertozi who is a
professor at Worcester Polytechnic
Institute and the third one is John
Slater uh who is um who started his own
business it's called Uh Vision energy
home so he's a he's a home builder in
the state of New Hampshire so I just
wanted to make sure that I wish you knew
who are the four people that were
involved me and the other three in
getting this thing started again thank
you representative Woodcock do you have
a question are you cheer on that thank
you yeah good morning good morning
gentlemen um Scott when uh Sigmund came
a few years ago uh in the car in the in
the dialogue of their reports they
present you were presented a through the
commission a listing of things that they
that were suspect in terms that we
hadn't finished completed
um and we have not at least I have not
and I may be a Miss but I have not seen
anything like that so my question is are
there still areas that have not been
completed or is that chat graph you use
typically filled if you know what I mean
yep so thank you I can I can speak to
that so uh
interestingly two very very different
colleges right
um and in this case
um New England iron article has
fulfilled substantially all of the all
of the uh
I don't say conditions because that's
too strong but conditions that that the
review team
um uh laid out in their report and at
this point any AI has fulfilled all of
those okay and in fact
um is much further ahead in the process
in many ways than we than than really
Sigma was when when they came for a
program
thank you and and for me it's not a
question but it's the comment um I'm
gonna support the program and uh just as
a CTE person uh sau9 where I'm from has
an aviation program in the high school
and works out of Eastern Slope uh in
Freiburg and it's really going great
guns catching on yeah thank you Mr chair
you're welcome
reps Damon do you have did you have your
hand up
yes thank you Mr chair and good morning
everyone
so I was just curious for a little
further history did the pre-existing New
England aeronautical Institute Grant
degrees
as far as I know yes
and then if I may
pulled it into Danny Webster uh yes or
it was renamed I became Daniel Webster
because uh The Institute was it started
as a flight school and then it um
uh it became a a degree grounding
institution but um the reason why I'm
hesitant to answer your question
directly it's because there's no
definitive history in regards to that
some people are are there even right now
that they have degrees they may be
associate degrees and not Baccalaureate
degrees so that's why I'm not exactly
sure but yes they did have degree
granting Authority thank you
yes represent Myler and then represent
cascadden thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here to help clarify
Arkansas some of our questions
uh Mr Appleby presented to us on the
29th of uh March indicating that this
program is primarily an aviation
Management program is that that's
correct am I correct in uh it is an
aviation program I wouldn't uh classify
it as an aviation Management program but
it's definitely an aviation program but
it's not a pilot training program it is
definitely not a pilot training program
yes it's not a program that focuses on
training commercial pilots
that's your question right right yeah we
don't train up well if I may there are
two components in training a
professional pilot one is a academic
component and the other one is an actual
flight training component so the
Institute is not involved in Flight
Training at all it's a it's an academic
it's a college uh it's a uh it's a
college that focuses on providing
undergraduate education with focus in
aviation and and Mr Appleby indicated
that that you are strongly capitalized
could you explain what that means
I would think
it relates to two different sorts of
Capital One is human capital which I
think we are very strongly capitalized
and the other one is uh Financial
Capital which I also think we are we're
strongly capitalized what we did was we
we try to focus our efforts based on
very prudent strategic planning based on
best practices so as far as human
capital is concerned the chair of our
board is George
Antonio's owns the largest Aviation
company Aviation related company in New
England not just in the state of New
Hampshire it's based out of of Peace So
he actually is the chair of our board I
mentioned the other three members so of
of the board we have the Provost of the
University of New Hampshire as a member
of our board
we have other people from
academics or when the Hyatt the member
of our board who is in charge of Co-op
at University of Massachusetts Lowell uh
and um we also have uh Senator Susie on
on our board as well as a professor from
the University of Texas uh who is
actually a management strategy professor
and the executive director of Kappa
Kappa is the Coalition of airline pilots
Association so it's basically the union
that represents all pilots in the United
States uh and interestingly enough even
though she's based in DC she's from New
Hampshire she's originally from New
Hampshire and very eager to to help
support this initiative so so we're I
believe in terms of uh human capital in
terms of as reflected on our board we
are very strongly capitalized because we
have people with Aviation experience
with higher education experience with
um you know industry experience and
international experience as well as far
as finances are concerned uh what we
decided to do is basically
take a prudent approach as far as
financial management is concerned so to
to spend what we need no more and that's
really what we have done so we've been
very prudent in our spending and we have
not acquired nor do we plan to acquire
any debt in building out the Institute
so uh the people that have actually
financed the the Endeavor is is a is the
owner of a flight school uh who is also
a member of our board as well as Mr
antoniadis who I mentioned before uh so
this is where we have drawn and and some
of our personal funds as well because we
believe in the initiative but this is
where we've drawn the um the capital uh
in addition to that we have
uh we have secured a surety bond with an
insurer so that and we already have that
even though we don't have any students
yet but we do have the bond in place uh
so that we protect potentially
especially in the first years of
operation uh students that um
would enroll in The Institute I hope
I've answered your question yeah you
you've gone beyond the my question but
but you have answered you have answered
one of the questions because I was
wondering about the Fidelity Bond yes
because one of the issues that this
committee has had to deal with is to
ensure that if something from a fiscal
standpoint uh the institution would
cease to exist we don't want to have
students who are then uh who are then
out uh their uh tuition so thank you for
that clarification the other question I
have too is I'm assuming based is this
is this a four-year program so that
somebody at the end receives a Bachelor
of Arts degree yes sir yes Bachelor of
Science and how many students are you
anticipating to be engaged in this uh
program we have right now recruited five
students uh to to run a pilot program no
pun intended to just basically test the
um uh the the our our educational uh
model to test our technology uh to
basically test the way that um uh we are
planning on running the institution so
so these five people are aware that they
are
um the uh in the in a group of um of of
pilot testing this uh this program uh we
actually think it's going to be a very
successful program uh in the future I
can tell you about my experience with
Daniel Webster and things have moved
forward significantly since the Daniel
Webster times but the reason why I was
recruited to be the dean of Aviation
Sciences at the Fairly young age at
Daniel Webster it was my experience with
distributive education with the with the
uh
hybrid program is called at Concordia
University I was a director of a
master's degree program at Concordia
University which was hybrid and that was
a very successful program
um Concordia in Canada in Montreal and
at Daniel Webster for a master's degree
program in
2007 because it's when it got started
the second year we had 100 students so
here
what online education means in today's
world is totally different than what it
meant in 2007 so the potential for
online education is more significant
right now here we have a bachelor's
degree program so the the the group of
people that could potentially draw from
is enormous and Daniel Webster's efforts
were focused on the U.S market not on
the international market our efforts are
going to be focusing on the
international market actually our
curriculum is so incredibly unique
nobody else has it because nobody else
can actually do it we have combined the
thinking of the Federal Aviation
Administration in regards to flight
operations training and the European
Aviation safety Association uh nobody
can do this not even Embry little
Aeronautical University which is uh a
very very important University as far as
Aviation education is concerned so we
think
um I'm sorry representative Miller I'm
an academic so when you're giving me the
floor I tend to uh perhaps speak a
little too too much but um so we think
it's going to be successful because
without
without any effort we have five students
when we actually started when we
um when we have our website live our
website exists and and the folks at the
commission have actually seen it uh but
it's not live because we don't want it
to be live until we have approval
through the legislature we want to be
very very careful in regards to this
after we run our pilot testing and we
work through the Kinks the issues that
we're sure actually exist despite the
fact that we think it's a very um
um uh a very Noble and Innovative
curriculum and approach we will use
social media we will advertise we will
use business to business we already are
in touch with Kappa as I said before
Coalition of airline pilots Association
we're in touch with United Airlines
through their AB initial program called
aviate and they're actually eager to
work with us as well as with several
organizations outside of the United
States so this has the potential of of
attracting hundreds of students in the
future thank you just one final question
as a graduate of your program
what will I be able what kind of job
will I be able to get thank you very
much as a graduate of the program uh you
could be an airline pilot this is a
highly sought and very professional
um occupation so essentially uh however
we're not going to be offering pilot
training but if a pilot receives their
training let's say Nigeria or in at the
Concord airport at the flight school at
Concord airport uh we will be offering a
credit for that
otherwise they will take the grounds
portion that's what I mentioned before
not the flight portion just the the
academic portion uh with us so they can
they can become Pilots airline pilots
corporate Pilots flight instructors or
they could work in management functions
for an airline for a corporate Aviation
um for for manufacturer uh and actually
we have one of the five students is a
flight attendant uh she she works as a
flight attendant and she's interested in
getting this degree because she has an
aspiration to to move uh into a
management position and with a degree in
aviation the degree is not in Flight
Training the degree is not in Flight
operations it's a Bachelor's of Science
in aviation so it captures
um everybody
thank you representative cascad and then
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
you answered a lot that I asked but you
made me think of some other questions so
I'm sorry uh do you plan to recruit in
high schools and what is your targeted
date to Launch
we would thank you so much uh
representative
um we would like to launch in uh in
October of this year
um so our first regular semester to be
in October of um uh 2023 after uh
finishing with our pilot testing and
making sure that everything is in order
by the way we've already recruited The
Faculty uh the fact we have been trained
in our model so we're ready to go in
terms of that and we're building
um some of the details in of the of the
curriculum uh yes absolutely we would
like to
um
we would like to uh work with high
schools and um
um the representative before mentioned a
high school and Innovation program in a
local high school I was part of the
effort to create uh these types of
programs in New Hampshire high schools
and I've done this in Canada and I've
done this in Greece and I've been a
major supporter of stem education with
an Aeronautics Focus starting at a young
age I've worked with aopa which is the
aircraft owners and piles Association
towards that endeavor here in the United
States uh Daniel Webster we had Ace
camps from the FAA that we brought high
school students on campus but this is
even better the campus goes to the
student rather than the student having
to go to the campus and so yes the
simple answer to your great question is
absolutely high school students are
incredibly important they're the future
and as far as I'm concerned they need to
start understanding ending the industry
and the industry that needs to be much
more inclusive
uh which is but it needs to be even more
and to do that you have to go to 11 year
olds and uh and show them what they can
actually do uh and and get them started
uh from uh from there so yes and and we
want to do this we want the the New
Hampshire name to be or the the quality
of higher education the reputation of
the quality of higher education in New
Hampshire not only to be maintained but
to be enhanced through our our efforts
uh because I think one of the advantages
we have is that we don't have any Legacy
structures or costs or or anything
everything is new and and we look
towards uh the future so again yes high
schools are incredibly important for us
but we're also there for professionals
believe it or not there are a lot of
people around the world that fly the
planes you fly in as passengers that do
not have bachelor's degrees
uh because the industry is so dynamic
they found jobs before they were able to
complete their degrees or they never did
um some of them if they lose their
medical
they they're high school graduate so a
lot of these people would like to have
this degree and again a lot of these
people are not just here in the US or in
New Hampshire
they're all over the world and and
that's what we're trying to capture so
so thank you so much for your question
representative McDonald thank you and
thanks for taking the question really
for the expertise regarding this issue
you mentioned that you were an online
institution based in Hollis New
Hampshire but also that you do not have
degree granting or priority at least not
at this point in other states would that
limit students from other states from
taking part in this if you had say a
Massachusetts name Vermont et cetera
resident who wanted to get a degree from
neaai would they still be able to
um
that's a fantastic question and I can
maybe start answering but uh executive
director Appleby uh can definitely um
answer to the the more structural issues
uh in terms of that by the way our we
filed our initial paperwork the five
friends
um I I really dare to say this uh
because that's really we're five friends
that did the initial paperwork for the
Institute
um over three years ago now
um using uh just a residential address
but our address right now is uh 101
flight Line Road in in Portsmouth New
Hampshire so it's at PACE Air Force Base
so so this is the the base of this
institution of this institute is peace
Air Force Base which is really the
center it or it should be the center of
Aviation activity as far as the state of
New Hampshire is concerned
um there is a uh a federal law which is
which called NC Sarah which we are not
not going to participate right away so
we will be available for New Hampshire
residents to to register initially as
well as residents from other states that
are not signatories to NC Sarah
we cannot participate in NC Sarah yet
because you have to be accredited before
you do the paperwork to participate in
NC Sarah so if a resident of a state
that and this will be disclosed on our
website but if a resident of a state
that is NC Sarah signatory
applies then unfortunately we won't be
able to admit that individual follow-up
please yes
are so this is New England's
aeronautical Institute are the other New
England states a part of that and would
the students from those States be able
to participate
thank you for the question
representative so uh the the Sarah
agreement encompasses 49 states
currently uh the state of California is
not a signatory to the agreement and
really what what Sarah allows
institutions uh to do is not go state by
state to receive approval for their
degree uh in the in the case of any AI
if they wanted to enroll students from
Massachusetts they would need to seek
approval from the state of Massachusetts
it isn't degree granting approval like
this but every state and we have the
same process here in New Hampshire every
state
um has their own framework shall we say
and rules around approving out-of-state
programs if they're signatory to Sarah
and the institution that's remote to
that state is a signatory to Sarah well
then that's all that needs to happen and
they're approved to operate in that
state however for us we get a
significant number of california-based
Institutions will want to offer an
online program here in New Hampshire and
the higher education conducts a review
of that program and then approves
or doesn't approve that program to be
offered in New Hampshire but that's just
California every other state is a member
of Sarah and so in the case of any AI if
they did not yet have
um accreditation and therefore could not
be a signatory to Sarah they then would
seek approval individually state by
state okay so and that's an additional
process more paperwork that's yep and
they would go and that would involve us
here in New Hampshire except to confirm
what we've already done right but other
than that it's up to Massachusetts
Connecticut Rhode Island and so forth
thank you
we authorize
experience
group of main recommendations
when you're cheering this how would you
rate this application in terms of some
of the other situations we've gone
through
recommendations or
issues that she received or seen well I
think we look at each other these
institutions a little bit differently as
we look at it I will say this about this
is definitely a startup and I think we
looked at it as a startup it's
it's got issues that we are going to
have to be dealt with with uh faculty
and it's got issues it's going to have
to be dealt with financially
but we looked at the board we looked at
the all the elements of how they did
their plan
and we asked a lot of questions
also had to do with what their financial
situation is and I think that's a
bootstrap in some ways as it goes
forward but I want to tell you after we
had a discussion we voted for it
unanimously so how would I rate it
against the others it's so different
than some of the other institutions that
we consider that it's sometimes
difficult to do a comparison from one or
the other what we really look at is what
is the
results of the study and what have they
done to prepare to be able to offer a
good solid education for their students
and when we went through that they
looked very good but they're still to be
proven I mean this is really an early
process I I don't want to mislead
anybody to say this isn't like an
established institution somewhere
wanting to start something in New
Hampshire this is an institution that is
really starting pretty much from the
ground up but with a lot of skill sets
brought from a lot of different areas to
make it so that we felt like as a as a
commission that they had brought the
skill sets together to be successful in
their Endeavor and they also feel what
we consider to be a whole in some of the
educational environment that's out there
so the combination of what they were
doing the novelty of of how they're
approaching it the need in that area and
the quality of the individuals they have
brought together to run and set this up
assured us that they had what was needed
to be successful now we're going to have
to check with them from time to time to
monitor their progress but I think it's
hard to compare it against another
institution that might want to do some
things here because it's so original in
its idea and concept but I think they
are well prepared for what they're
trying to accomplish and do
another question
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
again for uh for joining us uh here this
morning and and uh and I know you have a
a lot of things on your your agenda a
lot of things to do
um uh just a couple of a couple of
questions uh one of them actually when
did I guess when do you expect to
we are going to start accreditation for
us
um
right now or I think internet
accreditation is twofold one is Aviation
accreditation uh there is uh an
organization called Abby Aviation
accreditation board International uh
we've already started a discussion with
them uh and uh to be able to actually
start the process of accreditation you
have to have at least one graduate so
it's not something that can happen
overnight uh and the other one is
business education commission and the
process is uh also very similar so our
effort starts
has already started towards these two
accreditations that will be uh important
but it will be a process just like uh
regulatory process here uh it's going to
be a process but we're prepared for it
by the way I'm a member of the Board of
Trustees of of Abby uh and I've worked
on nature accreditation before uh very
successfully for also another startup
institution I worked on and my my
colleagues also the academics are very
familiar with uh with this process
um so uh it should be yeah it's it's a
process and uh we have to have at least
one graduate to get it started okay and
then and then a follow-up to that Mr
chair actually I think um goes to uh Dr
Burks or um or Mr Appleby with respect
to the the higher education uh
commission
um uh doctor you talked about how you
you follow the
um the schools that have applied for um
granting Authority you know through the
process because obviously this is
I don't know one of the one of the early
steps and there's a lot more year
potentially years more
um uh steps
ahead of us and you've you've described
um uh any AI as a startup and I think
that's a fair a fair
um uh way to describe it and without
making any you know negative aspersions
on things I've been involved with
startups before some of them take off no
pun intended uh others um you know I
will avoid using the the crash word but
uh
um
but um but but should things not
um you know you know not continue down
the road
um how do what what what steps does the
higher education commission
um take at that point now that the state
has has approved degree granting
Authority and I'm just wondering what
what happens when during the breakup
start
I'll let Steve say some more but I'd say
from our perspective this is like the
first or second bite out of the Apple
and what we have to do is track that
process and and see how they're
succeeding as time goes on I think we
have another session later in the year
where we get together with them so
um it's not an unfamiliar process that
we go through to check out institutions
because there are institutions that have
struggled from time to time and we
review them and make suggestions and
then we make decisions on how to go
forward uh Stephen
thank you for the question all they
would add to to that is we have a number
of Institutions both in state and out of
state that we require an annual report
from
for the commission and that in your
report you know could be just a and even
current institutions that have a new
program that's a new degree outside of
their their functional area
um they provide us a new report that
talks about how many students finances
um outcomes and that annual report gets
filed with the commission every year and
in the in this case it would be a rather
extensive report versus just one
particular degree from an existing
institution which might be two pages you
know we would expect to see a multi-page
report really addressing every single
standard in our administrative rules and
how their progress is tracking towards
those standards and those are the
standards that line up with netchi
standards as well and then just just to
make sure I I understand this again this
really has nothing it's not specific to
any AI but I I think it's more more
specific to the process of approving
um degree granting Authority since we
don't do this very very much in this
committee I mean we've we've probably
heard 300 bills since um since the last
time over the period of years here in
the 15 years I've been here we have
approved a number of authorized yeah a
number of Institutions and working with
the commission and the commission
members uh are are folks which come from
all our Public Schools the presidents
and then we have non-public higher ed
involved folks appointed by the governor
uh it's a really
um uh uh professional a knowledgeable
commission which we've tagged this huge
responsibility to so so I do it yeah so
the the question here
um is and and I think
um Mr chair you you you you laid it out
really well when you talked about over
the years we've we've had a number of
applications uh you know I think uh
certainly prior to my time on this
committee and maybe prior to my time
being in the legislature I had I had
um seen some news reports on on colleges
that were granted degree granting a
given great degree gramming Authority
and then subsequently folded and I was
wondering is there a point at which the
higher education commission says no long
you can no longer operate with any
thank you for the question I'm just
thinking through
um there's one example in my 18 years I
was on the commission for 10 years prior
to coming to the department
we had one we had one case
back around probably a dozen years ago
now it was the Italian
College I don't know if you were even on
the commissioner that was for you so it
was a while ago and I'm trying to recall
exactly how we handled that situation
if I recall we never actually approved
them as a commission they had applied
they had trouble fulfilling requests
they had trouble proving finances
um and this went on over the course of
several high-red commission meetings But
ultimately they were never given degree
granting approval
um it never even came to the legislature
it didn't get out of the commission so
should something happen to a to an
Institute that has received degree
granting approval does that have like
I'm not aware that that that it gets
rescinded by the legislature does it
could it be rescinded by the higher
education commission this yeah there's a
couple different points these issues
weren't too prevalent maybe 10 years ago
they've become a very big part of the
accreditation process for every
institution right now I think netchi is
reviewing maybe 100 institutions that
are in some state of struggling so as
they go through the accreditation
process there's not only going to have
us looking at them but they're going to
have other institutions that are
accrediting them looking at these exact
issues because
they've become such a part of higher
representative Tanner
thank you I just it's kind of an
interesting question
um why do you call it an Institute
rather than a college or a university
I've noticed that that there's a
aeronautical Institute out of Washington
DC and it just seems like to separate
yourself you would be a college or a
university
we focused on on tradition and we wanted
to reinstitute
the New England aeronautical Institute
which was and is known to be a New
Hampshire institution with a long
tradition so that's why we called it a
an Institute there was no other reason
whatsoever perhaps in the future as NAIA
became Daniel Webster we may consider
renaming it but it's only for historical
reasons and and for no other reason
whatsoever
you know why is RPI called RPI
yeah yeah
so yes representative portiello thank
you Mr chair and thank you all but I
don't know exactly who to direct this to
um since you're seeking
uh you know a bachelor degree status
um obviously this is not just a
technical program
and so what I would like to just hear
more about is sort of the
non-aeronautical aspects of the
curriculum sort of do you have a Core
Curriculum what does that consist of
so
absolutely it's uh the curriculum is
broken down in three parts very
conventional in terms of higher
education and the federal guidelines I
have been followed in regards to
building the curriculum in regards to
the proportion of general education
versus uh Major versus specialization
and these are the three components so
one-third of the curriculum is general
education one-third is what we call core
and the other one third is the uh is the
major so gen Ed I'm sure you're very
familiar with it uh it takes a very uh
Civic engagement type approach to um to
general education I think it's very
forward thinking uh we have arts and we
have Sciences as part of that
um critical thinking very important
history so on and so forth and the
second piece is uh the um the the the
major the core which is basic basically
what everybody
just the the general knowledge as far as
Aviation is concerned how an airport is
run how neural land is run how Air
transport management is run about safety
risk management security and so on and
so forth and the third piece focuses on
more specialized
information that has to do with flight
operations again it has to do with
regulatory structures it has to do with
flight Dynamics aerodynamics things like
that
you know it's almost ready to Institute
the three-minute rule well
okay it's quick I just I just want
clarification and maybe I missed this is
this like 100 online now that you're
proposing do you have any anticipation
of any kind of brick and mortar when I
think of like airplanes and stuff I kind
of think of like maybe Hands-On
um
it's only the uh the theoretical part
it's only the academic part that we're
actually actually focusing on so yes it
is online and it's not just online it's
as synchros online to be able to uh to
focus on that
good question thank you so again nobody
who graduates
will be a pilot just because of
graduation they may be a pilot already
or they may be somebody who is training
to be a pilot and is doing that is doing
the theoretical piece
um together with that but uh the only
actually the only
um uh course which is
um challenging in this type of an
environment it's the Physics course it's
none of Aviation courses
um it's the Physics course and we
actually have uh have built a virtual
lab for for the Physics course because
this is a fundamental very important
part of um of general education uh and
board International in terms of how this
knowledge is structured how these uh
represent Damon
thank you so too I think related
questions
how many students do you think you need
to be a viable operation and then I'll
connect that to the other
um
the business model we are using is one
that focuses on variable costs there's
very little in terms of fixed costs that
are associated with um with the school
so even so every course to be able to
run successfully and make a profit needs
three students at least three students
because all the costs are associated
with the instructors instructors get
paid by the student and not by the
course
are a lot of schools in Europe a lot of
universities in Europe do that uh and um
it's uh it's a way to do it so basically
if you have 10 students you get paid for
10 students you have three students you
get paid for three students because you
don't show up in a classroom and spend
an equal amount of time you spend enough
time individually with with each of the
students going through a um and right
now I mean higher education is all about
deep expertise it's not about lecturing
uh and you know I hold the knowledge the
knowledge is everywhere you have to
guide the students so that's really our
our model there so uh to be more direct
in terms of answering your your question
uh we believe and and the the financials
are are available uh that the commission
has them uh there's a five-year budget
there's a five-year plan I'm sorry
there's a budget uh there's startup
costs and then operational costs that
are factored in technology and so on and
so forth we expect to be um
uh to break even after three years of
operation uh with approximately 50
students uh and and anything beyond that
uh should be
um should be profitable and this profit
as a not-for profit will be reinvested
in in building this institution because
we already have as Strategic Management
Theory tells us we already have in our
mind a growth plan I mean we actually
want to move into uh some other areas of
Aviation that we believe we can actually
serve but have to start from somewhere
so
related to that then
are you confident of the availability of
the faculty that you need for those
numbers of students because I know in
unrelated areas of higher ed say nursing
lack of Faculty is inhibiting enrollment
of students absolutely we are and we
already have a Cadre of Faculty which
are from from all over the world
actually they're they're uh they're
based here in the United States they're
based in New Hampshire uh in other
states in the U.S in Europe
um and uh yes uh and because our
approach it's not geographically
confined and that's why it's easier to
be able to uh to tap the talent that we
actually need
representative Ford thank you Mr chair
and
thank you for taking my question
as soon as I get hooked up here
um
do you have Provisions already for
students transferring say from community
colleges and other places to do various
parts of your program uh yes sir we do
and they are part of our institutional
catalog these policies have been written
they've been vetted and they've been
approved by the higher education
commission so the clear answer is
absolutely yes and we actually expect
quite a few students like that perhaps
somebody who already has again a
commercial pilot's license and no degree
they can transfer credit based on that
on that license uh somebody coming from
a community college or or a high school
student who has taken advanced placement
courses can can enter in uh so we have a
policy that holds its water in terms of
the commission as well as in terms of
Nazi I mean we took Neches guidelines in
regards to uh minimum amount of credits
uh every part for graduation maximum
amount of credits transferred uh so so
it's it's already there
thank you are there any further
questions Representative
no three-minute rule applies
um so I I was just looking up Abby on
the um on online and and looking at
their trustees and they've got quite a
few trustees obviously representing a
lot of very
um well-recognized institutions and and
companies but I was just wondering is
there a concern I know I I see Dr
Fleury's name also on the list of
trustees and I was wondering is there
any conflict given the accreditation
being a trustee on the board that is
accrediting the the new um uh uh
Institute there is not uh because
um I'm not part of the proceeding if my
institution uh goes up for accreditation
then I I have to recuse myself and
actually interestingly enough uh their
their recusals uh even if you uh
somebody there let's say is now the dean
not uh at Purdue University but got
their degree from memory riddle when
Embry Riddle is up for pre-acretation
that being from Purdue recuses herself
uh because uh she has a degree from an
institution that is going up for
accreditation so yeah it's a matter of
I'm on the curriculum committee as well
so if if anything comes up
um uh you know I've I've been I've set
up like partnership agreements with like
Bridgewater State University in
Massachusetts when they go up for
accreditation I recuse myself because
I've I've done business with them so but
and and that's not really a typical Don
you're president of PSU you are a
trustee you are chair of this Commission
any conflicts yeah yes you could say
we're we're pretty incestuous in this
head stat there's only so many of us and
we serve on these various groups so uh
just to use an example nache Keen uh
president Melinda serves on that CCA
just went through a review process had
to recuse herself you know as she went
through that process so very usual
because they want to have the best
expertise on these boards that we're all
involved in some ways or another but uh
we try to do it in a way in a process so
that we not only recuse ourselves but we
have to be response to the process and
when we go through an accreditation
process
we bring together experts from all
across the universities that are part of
us that uh bring all sorts of different
viewpoints I just did a review myself
and uh I can tell you uh the process and
the expertise you bring from different
directions uh sure is a pretty balanced
review of accreditation
thank you
are there any other questions from the
committee from all these experts in
front of us sounds like a wonderful
program
we wish you luck on it
not seeing any other questions thank you
you want to Executive let me get this
done okay at this time
um I will put forth a motion
uh I will put forth a motion to OTP uh
SB 24 second Dr Porter just stay here
first we're going to take it we're going
to take care of you right now so we have
on the table right now a motion of ought
to pass on a relative uh relative to
conferring a degree granting authority
to the New England aeronautical
Institute SB 24. we have a second made
motion made by myself and a second by
representative Miler any for any I have
no further discussion representative
okay is there any discussion from the
committee not seeing any uh Madam clerk
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative yes representative
portiello yes representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 20 years
so go on the consent calendar and
hopefully the house floor will take it
like that and sign to the governor
okay what we're going to do now is that
we're going to take a brief caucus we
have several other bills which we have
to address and
how much time do you need represent
miles
about 15 minutes okay we're going to
take about 15 minutes here to have a
caucus come back
and address the other bills which we
have in the docket
I don't know if there's any rooms
available across the way
uh continue our executive session and
we're looking first at SB 135 this is
relative to Alternative dispute
resolution and special education like
the recognize representative Ford for a
motion
OTP
is there a second from representative
luno
okay uh represent four do you have any
further discuss any discussion on the
represent luno no I'm good thanks you're
welcome
um are there any further discussion from
the committee represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I would like to
introduce a minor amendment to SB 135
Amendment 1411h which I did not pass out
yet I will do now we have enough oh I'm
sorry
foreign
's going around just to be a Time Saver
at the bottom all I've added here is uh
two sentences
alternative dispute resolution shall not
be initiated by the state or local
Education Agency in circumstances in
which the parent Guardian wishes to
refuse Services entirely and shall be
discontinued upon such refusal and this
is just a small
um change I wanted to make to head off
one potential problem I could see I can
see a lot of good things in this bill
but I have heard from some constituents
that because their schools may have
decided that they wanted to try to do an
IEP or something along that line but a
parent did not want that to happen that
this that in some circumstances the
schools have attempted to negotiate with
and convince them with over a period of
time to do it anyway and I can see this
potentially resulting in a circumstance
where the school says well we don't have
to do it right now but let's just keep
talking about it and let's just keep
talking about it as a something that
could happen over a long period of time
to draw this out when a parent it really
doesn't want to happen so I just I want
to make that clarification that if a
parent says no that's the final word
that's it
further discussion from the committee on
that bill representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair there's no need for
this language because I don't know if
you know the IEP process or the special
ed process but parents when they don't
want to go through a dispute they can
sign and refuse Services there's already
a form and a process for a parent to
deny
either continued Alternatives or
continued discussions
so there's no need for it
representative Lucas
yes I wanted to ask you about that
um you specifically
because you're familiar with this
um
in the dispute resolution you know the
the law that's in there the the
alternative dispute resolution
and it does say if it has been rejected
by the parent
then it establishes a 30-day period for
discussion
but if the parents is so
I guess that made it unclear to me that
the parent could absolutely say no and
that's the end of it
that it wouldn't go to this dispute
resolution
automatically
parent can sign a refusal of services at
any time based on that and that's very
end of it
unless they come back and say well now
we think they need speech now they
should have this they should have that
right
thank you that's what I like and that is
my understanding as well
um although there are some situations
you know may not be capable of making a
decision for the but then you wouldn't
be really in a dispute situation like
this but I in all the years as a school
principal I've never experienced a
situation if a parent does want to move
forward they don't move forward with
anything
Becky do you have anything on that at
all because you were a director and this
we we uh you see was there was there a
second on year did you put the the
yes I believe I motion the second that I
don't know if we had a second okay we
need that before we can have any
discussion on that Amendment we really
need to have a second on the amendment
did you second it Alicia all right or I
oh I can so we can discuss discussion
purposes okay
thank you go ahead Becky uh good morning
for the record Becky Wilson director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association uh
previously a special education director
here in the state for about 20 years
um I want to reiterate representative
cascadden's point which is
um there are specific rules around going
to due process when there is a
disagreement between the parents and the
school district for the very first
initial evaluation of the child or the
first identification the school district
has not allowed to pursue due process in
that case so if it's the very first time
a child's ever been referred you go
through the referral process you want to
offer the student an IEP and the parent
says no you cannot go to due process for
that it's legally not allowed there are
also sometimes though where the district
is obligated to get a resolution
through the special ed rules so there
are times where you can't just let a
disagreement hang out there you have to
pursue due process in order to get
resolution to meet your obligation as a
school district so there are very
specific situations in which you can and
cannot as a district file for due
process and that would be the only time
that a district would pursue something
even if the parent didn't want it in
terms of resolution not necessarily in
terms of doing what the district wants
versus what the parent wants if that
makes sense
and is this all based on premise on idea
it's based off the federal law and the
New Hampshire rules also supersede and
go beyond sometimes the federal law in
New Hampshire that we exceed a lot of
the federal idea with more options from
represent Belcher
thank you Mr just to clarify when you
say due process you're referring here to
the alternate dispute resolution process
thanks for the question the dispute
resolution process has multiple parts to
it
um if a district is going to go to
mediation or a parent wants to go to
mediation it's still part of the dispute
resolution criteria so there was
paperwork that the parents and the
district both have to fill out
collaboratively to file for the due
process as part of that you would check
off as a district and as a parent
whether you're willing to try mediation
before you go to a due process hearing
most often people will do that because
there's a very good chance that you can
resolve whatever the issue is in
mediation without going all the way
through to a due process hearing but
that's all part of the dispute
resolution options
go ahead just follow up on that so so
ultimately there there is no way under
current law that should a
parent refuse or refuse in IEP but the
school wanted to do it that the school
local Education Agency could then
initiate the alternative dispute
resolution process to try to negotiate
um thanks for that question so
the district does have an obligation
called child find to seek out and find
students with disabilities and ensure
that they are appropriately evaluating
those students to the extent that they
can with parental consent to offer that
child whatever Services they might need
to to in order to access their education
as part of you know annual evaluations
and things that are happening at the
classroom level there is a chance that
if they've already found that there's
some concerns for that child's education
they've referred the child they've gone
through that process and the parents
have said no thank you that the next
year so to speak maybe there's more
evaluations that are done you know as
part of classroom learning and there's
concerns that are again brought up the
school district has to respond to the
concerns they can't just say well you
know three years ago the parents said
they didn't want this so we're never
going to bring it up again that would
put the district in a position where
they're not really meeting their
obligation for that student they would
have to at least talk to the parent
about their ongoing concerns but the
parent still to Repco Adam's point would
have to give consent for further
evaluations or anything like that the
district though for its own liability
would need to document that they've at
least expressed to the parent that
there's some concerns in that area so
that when that child turns 16 18 they're
not saying you know you let us go our
entire School career without giving us
for represent Woodcock hey chairman this
is probably for you sir I just want to
be sure
um that uh the amendment doesn't negate
on the original Bill lines 15 through
19.
I'm specifically concerned about uh with
right so this this is only for two and
doesn't it it's going to be clear it
doesn't impact
those three lines that's only per
section two row number two section two
is not changed by this amendment okay
the the correct the number the the
non-roman numeral two correct I just
want to be sure that under in on this
initial bill is uh Rook on 7th 1819 then
you should agreeable 30 days is still in
there it's not the Leader by or negated
by this one
right
thank you very much Becky you're welcome
here I want to make sure I just did not
hate that so we have before us the
amendment
any further discussion on the men I will
just chime in on and support what I as a
principal for all those years
um I agree with rep uh representative
cascadden that this is a process that if
the parent says no that's the red light
yeah and this is we're done and done
yeah this is not yeah so the um so under
the amendment that that edition of the
the the uh designation of no no more
basically is already in law by by
federal law by the fair refusing uh and
and has nothing to do with I mean this
is just like repetitive and not needed
the parent walks out of that IEP meeting
it is done they sign off right it's done
yeah so
would it be your opinion then it's cheer
that those three lines are repetitive
well it's it's my opinion and it's just
just myself alone that as all those
years in school uh teaching in in
principleship where we did the
intervention process and when the IEP
process and
we did this regularly and and it was the
schools of 400 600 kids uh as a
distinguished National principal I have
no
uh understanding why that would be
needed seeing that a parent can say no
and that unless there's some extreme
situation like the the parent is
incarcerated and there's you have a
foster parent taking your care or
something but that parent is treated the
same then the state is there so I I
don't understand I don't think it's I
think it's duplicate of what we already
have in law
reps and electives
oh
so in making sure that you agree as well
and that everybody agrees that there is
no way
to enter into this alternative dispute
resolution
by anybody if the parent says no
it takes two to dance that's what I
wanted is that that didn't seem to be
exactly what she was saying and so I
but to say all in
there's always going to be some
exceptions and some situations which
occur
you have something else to add
inspirational Services they're not going
to pitch it or it says no no because
special ed has a lot of hard fast rules
but it's also a lot of thinking like
special ed as opposed to everything fits
in a box
the concern I would have personally
about the amendment is I understand the
intention of that Amendment and I think
99 of the time
that could not happen however the
federal idea and your New Hampshire
special ed rules require the district to
resolve things sometimes and sometimes
the only Avenue the district would have
would be to file for due process if the
parent was extremely non-responsive if
the parent was
um you know put If the child had already
been identified and the school district
felt that there was something else that
needed to happen and there was just no
resolve the district has obligations
under Federal idea to make sure that the
situation is resolved it's not
necessarily to force the parent to agree
but it is to resolve
or have somebody else resolve whatever
the disagreement is you can't just as a
district say well you know I'm going to
wash my hands clean of this and just
walk away you have an obligation to that
Stu to that student so there are
very few situations where the district
would file for
due process and as part of that maybe
mediation which is what this bill is
about
um
but the if the parent didn't respond to
that or didn't want to do it they would
never even go to mediation right the
mediation is an agreed upon thing that
both sides agree to and I believe the
intention of this bill is that sometimes
it takes longer than the 30 days to go
through the mediation process and if
you're on a good run between your the
district and the parent and you're
getting somewhere and it's the 31st day
the bill wants to give you more time to
resolve it that way so that you're not
going to a due process hearing
representative woodcock
thank you for taking my confused
question so if a parent is not
responsive
um that means they're already in the
process because you created the IEP and
they haven't signed him brought back all
right because they're already in it
that'd be a non-responsive parent a
responsive parent or would not I'm not
responsive parent wouldn't be in this
category because they're refusing that
is their response so they'd be out of
the IEP process at that point not not uh
omitting your the next year the teacher
wants it done puts in but that's that's
a whole different issue yeah thank you
for the question to representative
cascadden's Point earlier if the child
is in the already in the special
education umbrella under that umbrella
and there's things the parent doesn't
want or wants there's a process for them
to refuse those services and document it
and that would meet the district's
obligation to document that they've
offered and the parent doesn't want it
and it's documented and you would just
go on without worrying about that
I kind of equate this to what we just
finished doing with the first bill we
exec today
um we were not there when we did it the
first time and we needed to schedule
some technical advice and that
oftentimes will happen in in
disputes which you see you might want a
doctor to come down that doctor might
not be able to come one week or two
weeks what three weeks from now but if
you want to make the best decision on
behalf of that child and family you go
ahead and you try to extend this would
allow us to do that and get the
represent Belcher thank you Mr just to
just to fully clarify because if I
understand you correctly then it may not
be necessary but I want to be 100. so if
a parent it goes through the process
early on before this happens before this
would happen and goes to the process of
refusing IEP signs whatever paperwork is
necessary does that then there is no way
in which the local Education Agency can
file for alternative dispute resolution
against the parent to try to get that
IEP and then potentially extend that
conversation with the parent beyond that
30-day timeline to ask them to continue
talking about it
thank you for the question
um I'll say what I often used to say to
students always and never very maybe
don't ever say always and never there's
probably always a circumstance somewhere
hidden that would be you know not
predictable if a parent has refused
services or refused an IEP and they have
documented that and the district has
that in writing and they've gone down
the appropriate process to document all
of those things then no the district
would not pursue any kind of mediation
because what would you be mediating you
just the parent said no and that's the
end of it
we had a situation in school I had where
we were in a dispute resolution
situation and the child did have an IEP
the parent wanted that IEP parent wanted
more from the IEP than we could deliver
they wanted a total neurological
examination done up at Humana and
Anchorage and we were down 365 miles
down in Homer Alaska we had a hospital
right there we had the neurologist right
there and but it had to be the one in
Anchorage well you know we said no it's
not going to be that it's going to be
the person we have right here in town
and so that's what oftentimes the only
times I've been in this is for that were
you trying to figure out
get to the service you want to provide
to the student that students already has
an IEP
represent cascadden
well I've been in Lea to sign off on all
of these special ed processes and
it is the duty I mean we're dealing with
children there is no right there's no
wrong it's not clean cut black white
every child is different every parent is
different
and the school is responsible as
educators
to offer and work with a parent to the
ninth degree a parent is not always
receptive to the IEP process okay but
you're responsible to say what we think
we offer we have this we think this will
help that student growth parent
disagrees all right well if you need
some time to think about it
you have a right to refuse services
and if you want to think about it and
then explore yourself or don't agree
with an evaluation you have the right to
have your own evaluation maybe it proves
us wrong that's an option too
but this sentence
pegs the school against the parent in
his language that puts the parent in
complete Authority and you know what
they are
because they participate if they're good
parents in their child's education
another option they may go back and say
gee I heard at that private school my
child can get a classroom of five or six
students because they're over stimulated
in your public environment well then
come back in we'll meet the team if
that's going to be a better placement
because goals and objectives placement
two different things
then let's talk and let's go visit that
site and talk to that school and see if
that's a better fit for that child to
meet their needs
and then the school pays tuition if in
fact it agrees that that's
the model
but you can't just forget about it
you've got a kid out there that probably
has significant learning disabilities or
physical disabilities
and a parent can choose not to get any
help whatsoever the school must then
make accommodations to continue to
provide what they can for that child
under the parents supervision or
agreeing the parent might agree to an
accommodation rather instead of a
separate program they might agree to an
individual Aid within the regular
classroom versus having the child this
is a common one parents often don't want
their child to leave the regular Ed
classroom but they need to to get a
specialized say the Wilson Reading
Program because they're so they're
having difficulties
so if the parent disagrees with the
child leaving the regular classroom
sometimes the district will offer
provide an aid so that they can
accommodate within the classroom so
there's a number there's no one
situation that's going to fit for all
kids they're all individual but as a
public school and an educator
we have to show good faith effort to do
whatever we can to check to educate that
child
in any way possible but we cannot do it
okay at this point in time I'd like to
call to vote on this uh Amendment uh
before us we have Amendment 1411h
the motion is was to approve the
Amendments made by represent Belcher and
second by representative leckis
I want to just do this one by roll call
please
okay Mount Park would you please call
the roll representative Ford
no
representative boy no
representative Belcher yes
representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative courtiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no
representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock representative Hall no
Representative no
representative cascadden
no
okay two two eighteen two eighteen
so the amendment fails uh we're back to
the main motion now which was ought to
pass on 135 made by repson Ford and
second by representative luno
any further discussion on the main
motion here
now I'm clerk would you please call the
roll
representative board yeah
representative Boyd yes representative
blackis
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative yes representative
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Lino yeah that's representative Ellison
yes representative Wilcox
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes 20 years
consent thank you okay the next bill we
this bill is relative to nursing
certification requirements I Look to
represent McDonald to make a motion
thank you and I move ought to pass is
there a second
representative McDonald's would you like
to speak to your emotion yes this bill
would extend a process in existence that
would allow associate degree nurses if
they're in the process of completing a
bachelor's degree to continue their work
in schools this is critical to
addressing a worker's shortage and like
I said this program has been in
existence so this would be to renew this
availability this option I'd like to
take a second to thank all nurses who
are practicing a New Hampshire including
my mother and also all those that came
in support of this bill School nurses in
particular especially those who came
from the Salem and the surrounding area
so thank you
was your mother listening to this stream
rep Santana do you have anything to add
to that
um I would just say that this is a
compromise bill that I think really
addresses the problems that we've had
and that I would definitely second that
School nurses in particular have done a
yeoman's job and
um really thank you for everything that
they've done through all the years but
particularly the covet epidemic years
yeah thank you thank you any further yes
representative
Okay so
we have an amendment would you please
present your amendment I will uh this
amendment strictly just changes the
effective date and the effective date is
upon passage we heard there were two
problems one with the current nurses
with their six-year window is going to
close so that's immediate problematic
could be and then in the fall when
they're trying to hire new nurses it
allows them to
um have a a greater pool of applicants
so okay so is there a second okay
okay so further discussion repson Hall
you gave us a little bit of discussion
already okay
I don't have any more you're good with
that represent Myler yeah
any further discussion on the amendment
yes
um thanks uh
assuming this all goes through it goes
on you know goes to the floor consent is
there a way where we can um expedite
this through the enrolled bills process
um uh so that it gets to the governor's
desk in time for school nurses to be
hired and I think we do have a continue
uh don't we have an ape well we're past
it April 15th 15th usually
yeah we we need to try to explain as
quickly as we can we did have the
director of nursing from Manchester come
in along with the Nurses Association
supporting this uh we need the nurses
and so we either try to expect expedite
this a little bit quickly and move it
quickly
so that would be part of this record and
we will we'll do that
okay so we have an amendment in front of
us right now on this one right here we
we will take a a a
um a hand showing here all those in
favor of the amendment raise your hand
please
okay so then
um we have a motion done on the floor
would you like to make a motion
represent McDonald's yes ought to pass
with the amendment
is there's representative
okay thank you
so represent McDonald
recommends uh otpa on with the amendment
1414h and Reps and second by
representative Tanner any further
discussion
representative Ford yes
representative Boyd yes representative
blackis yes representative Belcher yes
representative try yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
yes representative Court Halo yes
representative Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes
20 years
okay the last bill to exec for today
is
sb216 making changes to the requirements
for the Civics education in schools I'm
going to hand the gav over to I don't
have a gavel but I'm going to hand it
okay yeah
discussion no no you gotta I gotta have
a motion made here we have a motion on
it on two one six two one six I'd
recommend OTP
we have a okay and the gavel back to me
um
we have emotional
OTP on 216 uh it's made by represent
Aladdin second by represent uh uh miler
uh I'd like to speak to the motion uh I
believe and always have that the issue
of civics education is drastically
needed in this state in this country and
from talking and hearing from those that
propose this bill for the Professionals
in the field that are recommending that
we uh require uh Civics taught as it's
recommended in the elementary school by
integrating this program into these
areas where it can be integrated or
embedded
um I think that's excellent and we can
start right off in the kindergarten
where everything you need to know is
taught in the kindergarten so we make
sure we hit the kindergarten and getting
up into the middle school years as well
uh with the program as it spells that
out
get my Amendment or the bill right here
um and again uh into the high school
where this required one half year of
civics
uh and that that instruction is very
very important as a requirement for
graduation
um all this is necessary as well as and
I don't want to negate as Senator Carson
had mentioned we asked her when she
introduced this bill what about those
other subjects like government and
history which and they are also we're
not trying to you know do away with that
in fact we're trying to maintain what
we're doing there uh so I I think this
is a good step forward Civics is has to
be uh emphasized in our schools more
just for a Civic society that we can
we're pretty much uh a split Society
right now and it's time to be able to
listen to each other and work together
and try to come to closure and if we can
teach this in the schools and teach our
Democratic process I I think we're going
to be successful and come out of this
Tunnel able to speak with each other and
have a society that respects our
Constitution and respects all that
stands for
representative Miler uh thank you uh Mr
chair I mean historically
I've taken the position personally that
this committee should not be demanding
local curriculum that should be up to
the
up the local school district to do this
I take exception to that historic
position on this issue
I take exception to it because I think
the bill has developed is very
comprehensive
and I want to reiterate a point that
chairman Ladd mentioned I'm very
concerned about the disability
in our uh
culture at this point in time
and the inability for people to come
together and to talk
and to share ideas and
try to dissuade people in a civil manner
respective positions
I think that this does provide an
opportunity to provide to heighten the
the issue
of the need to create a civil society
and it goes beyond content it goes be it
really is about people coming together
and be able to talk with one another uh
in a in a way that is not uh
antagonistic I mean we've often said you
know we can we can disagree but we don't
have to be disagreeable
and I think that's what I'm looking
forward to and I think by having this uh
not just in the high school level but
beginning at the elementary level where
kids can have a chance to come together
and figure out how to problem solve
I mean that's one of the problems we
have now is how do you don't just go to
respective corners and come out fighting
but how do you come to the center of the
ring and be able to say how do we solve
these problems that are facing us now
and I think that this uh this really is
going to be able to do that and I've got
high hopes but that as a result of this
as those children who started in
kindergarten in first grade in second
grade by the time they get to high
school and behind they become young
adults they will be able to change
what's happening right now in this
country which I am very disappointed in
so I totally support this thank you Mr
chair
uh thank you Mr chair I I I respect and
admire the comments of both of you on
this bill
just a a question uh in this committee
we generally come out against
high-stakes testing
as as a requirement for leaving a
program just I will make the point that
we now have added another high stakes
test writing it on top of this so that
at this point there are two tests that
you have to pass in order to do this uh
one will be the locally produced
assessment test that each School
District bus through and we are still
stuck with the naturalization test and I
would leave it up to you to decide which
okay I'd like to also hand the gavel
I'd like to move
uh Amendment 1394 which is an amendment
and okay okay I'll take it back second
okay okay so now we have a a Amendment
two two one six it is 11394 and I'd like
to speak to that now
um
I'm going to reflect a little bit on
what I saw yesterday when we had 130
pink slips handed into us and I saw a
hearing which was conducted in a way
that there are many Divergent positions
presented and we did it in a manner in
which I think we got through that
everybody had an equal opportunity to
present their position people listened
and that's what this is all about and
this is what Civics is now what I've
done in this amendment that you have in
front of you I've also looked at Roman
numeral one which is in this bill which
is language that's currently there but
part of that has been struck the part
that was struck says such instruction
shall not later than the beginning of
the eighth grade and shall continue in
all high schools is a component of what
one credit course of instruction
required for high school graduation in
the United States and New Hampshire
history
and a one-half credit course of
instruction and it goes on in the United
States government New Hampshire
government and Civics this bill is is
integrating into our statutes Civics
education and the bill that the
amendment I'm proposing does nothing to
change anything in the bill as it came
to us from the Senate
what it does do it adds one component in
there which reflects back in Roman one
here and it's listed as One D here a
one-year course of instruction in
history government and constitutions
United States and New Hampshire in high
school required for high school
graduation that's spoken to enrollment
one right now but we struck out the part
which talks about that one year course I
don't want to lose that I do not want to
see any part of the social studies
curriculum being at history our
government our civics
left out
and it's all important and I'm not
trying to negate Civics I I'm 100 behind
that but what this does it's put it puts
back in that one small component excuse
me and on one C down below uh in the the
in the bill that was presented to us
is spoke to
a school district shall develop an offer
the United States New Hampshire
government course under paragraph one
and Civics course under paragraph 1A
that's how it's written down this will
simply say a school district shall
develop an office the United States and
New Hampshire history government and
constitutions course and Civics course
courses under paragraph 1A
uh so it offers both of these courses
but it also mentions the components
which are in the first line of Roman one
which were not negated
and so this puts them back in the bill
so it means we're going to do the whole
nine yards here rather than ensuring
that we do a component a new component
the half year course in Civics at the
high school level we're also going to
have to have that year requirement in
the history and the government of our
country as well and of our state
so that's nothing new it's just just
clarifying in in the so I won't speak
any more to that
um are there other discussion on the
amendment
but you did second it I understand that
Mel
okay okay thank you represent cascadden
I just want to add to what
representative Miler said um I really
oppose curriculum that's driven from the
legislature versus from local control or
from the field
um but this bill is different I know
that this comes from work done by social
studies teachers and that's different to
me than something that's done from a
legislative body that doesn't have the
experience it doesn't walk the walk uh
so to speak
um I'm a little appalled it has to come
to that point
because my perception would be if it has
to be a law it's because somebody's not
doing it and they need to do it so I
you know I I'd like to just respond to
that a little bit and then represent
McDonald
um
I was a social studies teacher I was an
elementary teacher I wrote the main
studies curriculum project for the state
of Maine as New Hampshire and it had a
component of all these subject core
areas we also had in Title 20 in the
state of Maine it was also part of our
statutory language there are some states
which do write social studies
goals you might say into statute we've
sort of done that here uh to a degree we
put some major themes in there but we're
not I think it'd be wrong for us to get
down and say okay we're going to load it
up with a lot of this this this this and
this that is where the professional
field comes into play and that's where I
as a teacher came into play too and and
I I I've met a lot of our teachers that
are teaching social studies in fact we
have a fantastic social studies teacher
up in Woodsville he does military
history he does civics and he makes it
come alive and it talks about some of
the skills that are in this Civics
component right here where it teaches
people how to analyze and strategize and
to use the rhetoric that we were the
thinking skills that we've just recently
put into our adequacy
a statute so so that along with coupled
with uh
um the the communication skills or
excuse me the logic was we put in the
rhetoric is the communication with those
two I think this matches up very closely
to rhetoric and and logic and uh so I'm
all for this
um I think it's it's needed and I think
it also gives our social studies
teachers out in the field the strength
and the backup that they need right now
social studies unfortunately I believe
it's been put in the back seat since we
no longer
um uh address it the same way we do
reading right an arithmetic
furthest discussion represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair and I just wanted to
add on and respond to what you said
because I agree with you this Civics
instruction has not been taught or at
least to the extent that it should and
it should be taught in speaking to your
point Mr chairman I would agree with
that as well that it's not necessarily
the fault of our teachers because they
have other priorities in focusing on the
stem courses or science or math reading
and writing so in this bill the intent
is to put more time on Civics and just
emphasis for this and I think you
covered what I was going to say but it's
really to support the backbone of our
social studies teachers and it's
necessary at this time so
representative cascadden and
representative Damon just wanted to add
um the issue of the naturalization test
that's being given last Friday I had a
group from my high school for
representing Youth and government and we
had conversations about what the kids
were doing and whatnot
but the teachers were very anxious to
say to me
but we're getting ready to give that
immigration test and we need to get rid
of that we'd rather do our own
and know where the kids stand versus
taking that because of the time factor
that it takes and it's another thing so
I agree with representative Ellison to
really kind of look at that at some
point to repeal it thanks represent
Damon
thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to remind everybody in
case with the large number of emails
we've all been receiving that we did
receive a follow-up email from Janet
Ward who has been involved with the New
Hampshire Civics Coalition
reminding us that they will provide a
variety of curricular materials at no
cost
for all the grade levels to any District
that wants to access them so there's no
added cost to obtain materials for this
that is one option anyway
um and I want to just say that it is
such a pleasure to talk about Civics as
a bipartisan need and topic with this
group
and then lastly I'm going to follow
representative McDonald's Lee and
acknowledge my 93 year old dad social
studies teacher who is part of how I got
here
he would vote for this bill
recording this too
nobody else you'll see it every weekend
okay further discussion okay we have a
motion on the uh the table right now
it's an OTP on um
1394 uh age so it's the Motions just on
the amendment right now
everybody got that okay ma'am Kirk would
you please call the roll
representative Ford yes
representative Boyd yes representative
blackis yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Myler representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yeah chairman Ladd
yes
20a0 news
okay we have a another amendment uh
who is going to present that
okay
okay you're recognized for the make a
motion on the amendment thank you Mr
chair I would like to introduce yeah
Amendment 1423 H uh representative
cordelli's amendment to this bill that
makes a number of changes okay let's
let's get a second we'll do that and
then you can I'll second okay reps and
Ruckus
and I have read it okay go ahead
represent Belcher thank you and I think
the intent here though rep Cornelia is
not here today is to make minor
modifications that
um that do truly
um reflect the the bipartisan interest
that was expressed
um and the introduction of this bill
and I think the language that you will
find in this along with the values that
it recommends to be implicated including
honor humility Integrity contribution
and responsibility items that are drawn
from our own Constitution are all
consistent with a good Civics education
thank you
representative leckis do you care to
I do know that and I particularly love
seeing those parts of being Civic and
civil into
um into this and as mentioned they are
drawn from our Constitution and in part
could could either of you explain to
what are the new parts in this amendment
verse what is in the you know the bill
uh thank you Mr chair so first of all
section
um 1A it retains the same list but it
changes the the language and the
specific requirements within the list
for what is taught within the Civics
education
and what lines are that is that on that
would be page one lines
um
basically defines what Civics means
correct yes it defines what Civics means
within that within that section as well
I think that's the biggie is that where
it breaks it out
it's it's basically just giving a
definition of what Civics means in
okay and and this one right here you
it's it does not include
non-public and private Incorporated
schools
that Service public schools in the state
and up in Roman 1 we speak specifically
to public and non-public
yeah in Roman one it has public and
non-public yeah with the original bills
it's possible that in the private school
the non-public schools that is left more
to the non-public schools to determine
when and how they're going to do it but
in the public schools since that's what
we have oversight over
as this body we are saying
um these are the things or this is
you're going to make sure that you do it
in elementary school middle school and
okay this is from rep cordelli
um this amendment does four things one
it maintains in section one that all
public and non-public schools in the
state there shall be given regular
courses of instruction and history
government and constitutions of the
United States and New Hampshire
it removes however all the requirements
for course requirements in grade levels
and Civics components for non-public
schools in
Roman numeral one ABC it also removes
the Civics test graduation requirement
for non-public schools in Roman numeral
two on page two
I do not believe that the state should
be imposing those criteria on non-public
schools
number two it modifies Roman numeral 1B
Civics program comments it changes C to
specify freedom of speech and religion
number three it adds a component of
civics virtues as D the inclusion of
Virtues as a primary education comment
goes back to Aristotle
our Constitution Article 38 says a
frequent recurrence to the fundamental
principles of the Constitution and a
constant adherence to Justice moderation
Temperance industry frugality and all
the social virtues are indispensably
necessary to preserve the blessing
of Liberty and good government
a 2021 report titled educating for an
American democracy included this
challenges facing constitutional
democracy in the United States and the
need to set high expectations for the
knowledge skills and Civic virtues of
American citizens this report was led by
the organization I Civics founded by
Justice Sandra Day O'Connor
a report from the Bill of Rights
Institute stated Founders counted on
citizens to live out virtues like
justice honesty respect humility and
responsibility I believe to leave virtue
out of civics would be to leave out what
our constitution says is a fundamental
principle and certainly was considered
by our founders
and number four
adds a new section 2 on the last page it
adds Federal Constitution Day September
17th to the days during which school
shall conduct patriotic exercises this
bill was originally proposed in 2013 and
passed the house by a vote of 326 to 21
29 but died in the Senate
RSA 4 colon
13-c States the governor shall annually
issue on the following dates of
proclamation calling for a proper
observance of state constitution day
which is January 5th
the day which is January 5th and
September 17th as Federal Constitution
Day
so that the people may be reminded
annually on these dates of the blessings
of liberty
in 1952 a joint resolution of Congress
was passed which designated September
17th as citizenship day in 2005 law was
passed to mandate the civil and
educational authorities of States
counties cities and towns are urged to
make plans for the proper observance of
Constitution Day and citizenship day
and for the complete instruction of
citizens in their responsibilities and
opportunities as citizens of the United
States and of the state and locality in
which they reside our state had the
first written constitution in the nation
a six months
six months before the Declaration of
Independence
a 2008 Proclamation by the gov by
Governor Lynch pointed out that the U.S
Constitution went into effect in June of
1788 when New Hampshire became the ninth
state to ratify it
these facts should be a source of honor
and pride to every New Hampshire citizen
it is fitting and proper that New
Hampshire school children conduct
exercises on Federal Constitution Day so
that they learn about our rights and
responsibilities
I will conclude by quoting from a 2010
report from the New Hampshire Supreme
Court Society Civics education task
force
the task force included retired Supreme
Court Justice Suiter education
commissioner Barry members of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and others their
interim conclusions included
all New Hampshire Public School students
should study Civics starting in
kindergarten and continue the study of
civics through the 12th grade by the
time they graduate from high school
students should have gained the basic
knowledge experience and inspiration
they will need to engage meaningfully in
the Civic lives of their communities
their state and their Nation I ask you
consider my Amendment but I ask you to
yes representative
thank you chairman
um I have difficulty with this amendment
for a host of reasons the first is one
of the things we just talked about a
minute ago how fortunate we were that we
weren't hamstring local school committee
Local School departments with the
individual chapter reverse of what
they're going to put into their
curriculum we're allowing the local
school to do that and this is totally
obvious of that I'm not particularly
excited about we probably passed the
building includes all schools in New
Hampshire we take out non-republican
private school
and thoroughly uh
the section two at the end really seems
uh and I don't I don't understand it as
also a socialite teacher chairman that
at one point how we teach these these
virtues uh uh in a bypass away line 33
uh I think it's just it's really putting
teachers in difficult spaces uh and then
to conclude numbers at the end so I'll
make this one comment uh prior to at the
end of Page Three uh it's telling you
exactly what we have to discuss the
history of the pleasure leads and what
they mean what the pledge allegiance to
me or the Star Spangled Banner means as
individual content areas and then tell
them how they're going to prescribe
these patriotic exercises
laughs
as a veteran
and as a social studies teacher I don't
agree with this thank you
represent Miler yeah I would I would
concur with uh representative Woodcock I
believe this is a bit prescriptive and
we've we have a bill before us right now
and that has been worked uh through a
number of different uh entities
including uh teachers Etc and the Civics
organization within the organ within the
state and I I just believe that this
goes a bit too far uh and and would
agree with representative Woodcock so I
I will be voting no on this amendment
further discussion representative Luna
thank you Mr chair
um first of all I just wanted to thank
representative Noble for um for reading
those remarks because I think they were
very thoughtful and and in particular
the uh the concluding remarks that say
consider the amendment but pass the bill
and um and that said I also want to um
want to thank um uh uh Jay Khan Janet
Ward and Martha and especially Martha
Madsen for um uh for leading this um
this effort this bipartisan effort uh I
know it's included a whole lot of people
uh like uh like former Congress uh
congressman and um and chief justice
Chuck Douglas
um was also the um the um uh I think
attorney for the for for our uh uh New
Hampshire House of Representatives four
years ago and uh and I think that
bipartisan group has really taken on an
incredible uh role to to lead us in a
nonpartisan way of providing Civics and
instruction throughout the state and um
and you know we we talked about I think
a couple days ago how how the New
Hampshire house comes up with thousands
of great ideas every year and uh and I'm
sure we'll continue to to do that but as
it relates to Civics instruction I think
it would be tremendously valuable to uh
to vet those ideas through New Hampshire
Civics through through
um um um Ms madsen's uh organization and
uh and and leverage their expertise
their nonpartisan expertise in this area
for the uh for the benefit of all our
kids so so thank you guys very much
further discussion representative yeah
the comment and a question uh the
comment is
understanding of Civic virtues including
I would hope that all of our Civics
teachers could do that given that my
band teacher in grades three through six
instilled these ideas in all of us kids
at school I would hope a Civics
instructor would not have an issue with
helping us understand the Civic Virtues
Of Honor humility Integrity contribution
and responsibility
that's my comment my question though is
with regards to all of the things that
were mentioned in paragraph 1C
I
I is this not already in law except for
the addition of Declaration of
Independence and then down further it
says this section instead of paragraph
one
and public school or chartered public
school added in I mean I thought just
the bolds were the added things and the
rest of it was already in the law so
that's my question is that am I mistaken
I was I taught Civics also and you know
I I think that some of these uh
um items which are mentioned by uh
representative cordelli honor humility
Etc
of course I recall duty honor and
Country when I served and I think that
that is covered already in the uh the
bill when you talk about Civic life and
how life and the individual may be
involved in Civic life I think these are
basic understandings and I think what
we're doing by starting to you know
those terms which are identifying the
these these virtues
um it's sort of like the Boy Scouts
Creed Duty you know all that I can
remember having to memorize all that
stuff as a kid and that that's just when
we get down into that business we are
getting down into what a Civics teacher
is
takes that Praxis for and takes those
courses for it comes to school prepared
that's what I expect
the these will be integrated into you
know humility yeah you're gonna you're
gonna incorporate that into your
everything you do in school
um responsibility yeah you get your
homework in on time
um and just all those I I think when we
start starting to make a laundry list
there's always something on the laundry
list you leave out
and and we've experienced that in
statute so many times I'm getting to the
point where you know I I kind of learned
something the other day too when I came
in with an amendment on Friday and I
said well we need to put in the
Constitution first constitution in
America the constitution of New
Hampshire well we start making this
laundry list and and we got sort of a
little laundry list in there as this
right now which the Senate put in there
but uh I I I I I don't know if it's
really even necessary to do that
um so I think we can't get too
prescriptive and this is getting very
prescriptive uh so I I I'm gonna have a
hard time voting for this as well
um I think that I look at the the
signatories to this bill I look at the
front side there and it's pretty evenly
split between Senators that are
Republican Senators that are Democrat in
there and there's a hefty load of them
there in fact this is all Senators that
sponsored this bill
and um
I want to turn around and say to them
you guys got it right this time it's the
you know this time uh so
um I I'm I'm gonna just try to leave the
bill as much as possible to the way
we've done it and the deal with the
amendment which just tried to take part
of Roman one and put it down below uh so
uh I'm good the way we we have it
presented to us I'm not really
interested in in furthering this at this
time
represent Woodcock thank you chairman I
said I wasn't going to say anymore but
we just just got to some of it today and
I see and this this is the part that I I
find disturbing when we get three pages
of amendment the final four on it uh to
get all the little pieces off add it in
quietly in my opinion on line 26 what is
the edition of page one of the cordelian
moment is the addition of and religion
it was no and religion in the original
bill
and when you put using historical
references I mean we went through Garden
schools last year
and I just think this I think
I think just seeing this go through
adding religion into this pot
unbeknownst to everyone is questionable
as well and that's line 26 on the
Cordelia moment
representative
oh
line 23 sorry page two line 23. it says
that that's current law that's current
law
he's on page one
yeah
glorified section D in the original 26
no not sorry
yes represent Belcher I think I'd just
like to clarify on that particular point
that I think there perhaps could have
been worded or perhaps a comma and
another word in the right spot I think
it's simply referring to freedom of
religion and the importance of freedom
of religion which I don't think anybody
yeah which again okay any further
discussion so we have an amendment in
front of us right now
14 23h for the course would you please
call the roll
no
representative Boyd no representative
Lucas yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative yes
representative Cordele yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
oh did I do myself okay I'm sorry a
little off today Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
representative Hall no Representative no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd no
seven years
okay uh I'll make the emotions here okay
so I'll move uh otpa hot pass is amended
uh 216 and it's the amendment is 1394.
yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I wanted to hold my
comments for uh after that particular
Amendment
um I will first say there is a lot of
very much like within the specifics of
this bill
there are however a few things that I
have considerable concerns with
um not the least of which being
page one lines 23-24 the acquisition of
skills such as the ability to analyze
text in the term the reliability and
biases of sources now under normal
circumstances that may not seem very
objectionable but I think we need to be
honest with ourselves that our Civic
institutions as they currently stand
perhaps are not healthy enough nor is
our body politic in agreement enough to
be handing over the teaching of what is
or is not biased material
um outside of the home
that is one considerable problem I have
because that's going to run up against a
lot of ideological problems and it's
going to cause issues the second
significant
um issue that I that I see here is not
in the language of the bill itself but
it is something that's enabled by the
language of the bill we heard testimony
um and we've heard that there's going to
be curriculum provided for free
uh to fill these Civic requirements now
we are expanding the Civics education
with this bill and we're hearing that
this curriculum is going to be provided
I did quite a bit of research on this
curriculum and I have to be honest this
curriculum is anything but nonpartisan
and non-biased
this curriculum makes assumptions
such as this country is a progressive
bureaucracy with a living document
Constitution that is to be reinterpreted
according to the times
both of those are debatable matters and
political matters I would I would take
issue with both those personally I think
the proper way to interpret the
Constitution lies somewhere between
originalism and textualism not a living
document
so this we're running up against issues
here that were we know we're going to be
instituting a certain curriculum
and through this research I've
discovered this curriculum
is is not nonpartisan and the only thing
worse than being Not educated is being
miseducated and I want to see students
educated properly and I think a real
bipartisan effort that at this would
have to remove those biases from this
program
bye
representative Miler yeah you know
we can look at alternative uh realities
all we want to
but this program was developed through a
bipartisan approach you've heard who's
been involved in this thing
and you've got people from the right
people from the left who came together
to create this
so I'm not about to sit here and try to
create an alternative Universe here
because I think what has been created
here is an approach
that is in fact bipartisan whether you
like it or not
and
um I think we need to move forward with
this and it's about time that we provide
uh
students from early elementary through
High School an opportunity to really
begin to hear the various viewpoints
around how this country was formed and
how Civility and Civics should be
and I'll make one last comment yeah I
like everybody look at the bill on page
one uh not page one but on the first
page where it says Senate Bill 216 and
foreign
ERS are truly
a bipartisan split you know of the
they're all supporting this bill
unanimously
so I I cannot understand why then that
we wouldn't be looking at it the same
way knowing where it's come from the
work that's gone into it and there is
there's even places in this law book
here where the Constitution has to be
provided to schools for instruction we
have that in there in the statute
uh so I I I I I think that Civics
instruction is going to be taught by you
know as a principal I'd look for the
best Civics teacher I could find
and when I did the interviewing process
I would ask them to explain
some things about Civics just like I
used to say to teachers coming in want
to teach elementary Reading well I'm a
great reading teacher well tell me a
couple thematic reading books that you
use in your classroom some that said
they were great readers couldn't tell me
one title
and so you know that was easy to Wade
through that so uh you know I think uh
what's taught in schools
is a result of top down that your
supervision your school your principals
in a school your school board the one
the set the tone and and uh right now
that to say that we're going to let the
the teacher in the classroom Wag the Dog
I don't think it's like that
you know I was in the classroom
observing the non-tenure teachers three
evaluations every year three
observations for each evaluation and
then when we got to the other part when
they were then tenure teachers
same deal not as often and we had some
kinds of different plans where a teacher
could work with other teachers and doing
the valuation there's a lot of different
ways of doing it and so you know I I
have to have faith in in the folks which
are are teaching yes everything's not
the way I'd like to see it and if
there's a lot of reasons why it's not
some of it's our fault because we have
so many rules and regulations and we're
telling everybody how to do things and
we are putting more on the plate than
the plate can hold so I for one am going
to very much support this bill
the way it's been presented and the way
we've amended it thank you
yeah
representative Ford yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Belcher no
represented dry no
representative Noble yes
representative yes
representative Coors yellow yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Paul yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
18 years two days
okay 18-2 consent yep thank you will
there be a Minority Report
no okay
okay now I just wanted to know if they
wanted then wouldn't go and consent
okay thank you so we're going to take a
break right now
I want to I want to compliment you
and I want to compliment representative
pattern now
Noble Gray Court yellow for the work you
did yesterday
I mean this was this was a very
difficult hearing some of you have not
had the experience of being in front of
a crowd that's passionate on both of
their sides and I just think I think it
was conductive I was just proud of this
committee and the way it was done and
and David and I were talking on the way
home this piece was something new that
never happened before and so when you
when you said at begin no no clapping or
anything when this began to go like this
I thought that was kind of cool because
it didn't break it didn't break the
protocol but it allowed people to kind
of say where they were on those issues
and my sense is that we may have started
a new new tradition uh in in that when
their hearings in that house but but I I
I just think you guys did a great job
and I really appreciate the leadership
that you all provide thank you very much
thank you very much thank you and we
learned another thing at that when you
hand the pink card in the eye ideas to
communicate
and when it's scribbled in such a way
that
Katie and I are over there trying to
decipher what we're looking at it just
my comment had to come out about the
cursive and Jen and Jen Jen needs to be
thanked too for the work that she did
too so it was another division thank you
Jen well thank you very much we need to
take a break and have lunch uh Nate and
Kate and Caitlin you've been waiting
here all day for 266. we are going to
get there uh how much time do we need
so we'll come back and we'll start at
one
30.
thank you very much for all your help
ladies
foreign
I
okay I I had a pencil Mark there too
and so we'll start on the top of page 26
then
I have a stop right in the bottom page
25.
so you're increasing from four to five
years
this is consistent with the federal law
so Essa requires
um a revaluation of the plan every five
years so if we're going to do it every
five years we should do the state and
now the legislative oversight committee
was there
this
so I and I think this is actually a
mistake that the department made so when
we first started working on this we were
using an older version of the law that
didn't have the oversight Committee in
it so I think we should actually put the
oversight committee back in there
okay so that's fine we'll put that back
there
okay
everybody agreeing to that okay
I think the just the oversight committee
it's in that responsibility list of the
oversight there's no real way to do it
to the general court and get any no that
would take years right and you would
never get agreements right so we would
prefer to be the oversight committee as
well okay
so we didn't really make any changes to
these sections at all except some just
Clarity and language and whatnot and
things like where it says the
commissioner we had to change it to the
Department
um
your determination year clarification
there
what's the difference between a second
uh
consecutive determination year versus
the second year because we don't do
determinations every year so the next
year there wouldn't so if somebody were
to be identified as a CSI school
um today we wouldn't do a determination
for three more years so there would be
no additional data in that time period
we wouldn't do a redetermination in the
next year so we would need to do
determination years and not consecutive
same thing consecutive years
commissioner Department yeah okay
commissioner designee for that one
everybody good with addressing me
.
the commissioner is probably not going
to be the person that actually presents
the reports of the State Board of
Education it will likely be me or Nate
or whoever is in those positions but the
person that's doing the technical work
the commissioner sells does not would
not be there probably the appropriate
person to to be presenting on some of
these are the your these are the reports
required for schools that fail to
provide a radical education by the
definitions of either ibass or pfas so
there's three years or three consecutive
years of reporting versus or termination
years of reporting so each year the
first year the school has to do a
certain plan the next year the school
has to do a certain plan
um and then
um so the
um so the commissioner has to provide uh
updates right now to the State Board of
Education on how how that is going and
so we just wanted to commissioner or
designee that would be providing that
information to the State Board
foreign
that may very well be prepared by by you
know you Caitlin and Nate or others but
um but if we've got
um uh schools that are unable to
demonstrate adequacy for three
consecutive years I think the
commissioner should be the one to answer
to the state board for that and um and
you know I think some could say that
following yesterday uh we need to have a
commissioner that that does actually
understand what the um you know what
what the expectations are and what the
requirements are for schools to meet
um to provide an adequate opportunity
for an education so so I get it that you
guys will be up there with the
commissioner but I think it I think it
is the commissioner
um who's responsible to the state board
and and accountable
um you know in this area and and but it
could be the Deputy Commissioner why why
not right but I think the accountability
goes to the commissioner and the
commissioner
um I I think it's important that the
commissioner be versed in in the
requirements
um to provide an opportunity for an
adequate education be able to explain
why us why a school hasn't for for three
consecutive years and what the
department has done to to try to correct
that situation and be accountable for
the failure of the department to let it
represent cascaden I'm stretching no I
have a question
um no it the thought crossed my mind
that how else I don't have a problem if
you're the designees because you prepare
it you know it you walk it
but how would the commissioner know
the situation in the nuts and bolts
to be able to even to converse about it
if he doesn't
do that last step of the presentation
how would he is there another means
where he would learn it would he I I
don't know what that answer is but to me
if he was doing the final presentation
along with the team he would at least
know
about those details because as a I don't
know my perception is
he should know all the nuts and bolts of
everything whether he's the one that's
presenting or not
how would he learn that how would he do
that you know what I'm saying and I
think representative Luna raised the
point that
if that's the final step of who the
reporting goes to or the accountability
and maybe it better be him so he would
know it otherwise
he wouldn't know it I guess unless
there's another means for him to
to know of that and yeah sometimes there
might need to be a designee I mean
whoever the commissioner is if they're
incapacitated or away or can't meet that
meeting
then the Deputy Commissioner should be
able to step in those shoes and be able
to be just as knowledgeable
so
this is provide reports provide them so
the commissioner could sign it does this
commissioner have to be the one
providing it or can that be done by
a deputy or a designee like tomorrow I'm
supposed to be
acting on behalf of the speaker
or in because I'm his designee right at
the trustees so but I do come back and
tell him what transpired right and he
tells me beforehand what he'd like or
not on a certain issue
I don't know it's as an administrator
you don't always have
yeah but you better be able to talk
about it yeah in detail and I mean we
saw a witness yesterday
you know that was reported that the what
there weren't some answers provided when
there should have been so it's a it's a
no situation if you're an expert in the
field
then you should know it
you know and I understand it's okay for
them to report it but I'm just looking
at who's responsible in the end if
there's an era
somewhere
who has to take the brunt of it so I'm
completely you can delegate all the time
but the one that's still responsible is
the person delegating that's true
so if the commissioner delegates you're
going to take you know do this report
yeah the commissioner knows he's still
responsible he better darn well know
what's in that report well you would
think
well you know I
it's all about leadership
you know what represent Tanner
go back on this a little bit
um and you see what actually you know
the all the different things that that
the department is doing you know assess
a sign require require the Department's
doing all that and then it kind of comes
down
uh to the last and meet quarterly with
school officials in the affected school
to assess the progress and then as the
as the culminary
Coleman well culminating thank you
culminating thing the commissioner or
Deputy Commissioner shall provide
progress reports annually to the state
school board I think that's like the big
thing at the end I don't think it's
something that that
um you know Department represent
Representatives or whatever just meet
with the state school board I think this
is a a big thing so I would agree that
it's either the commissioner or the
Deputy Commissioner
[Applause]
yeah and we're happy to leave it
commissioner I mean I I don't think we
should really you know spend all day
no no I I agree with that I mean we're
going through this to understand what
what changes are to 266 and to come up
with with I you know you know questions
and yeah I think I put a question mark
in circle of the word commissioner we
can work yeah we can vote for let's move
on no I mean and I think your your point
is you know well taken and we hadn't
thought of those scenarios so
yeah
because it does run the next chair it
does add more credibility however in
magnitude to that type of third report
that the commissioner is doing it I
don't know maybe the destiny be more
effective I didn't say it wouldn't be
more effective that may be as well
but if they're also going to be taking
direction from the state board that's
the commissioner taking direction from
the state board not you know okay let's
put a circle around it and a question
mark and we'll come back let's go on
page 29.
legislative oversight committee this is
where we moved the oversight committee
to from rsa193c which was about just
assessment to here
um same language uh we just thought this
was better positioned in this this
section of the statute rather the
assessment section I know representative
you had some questions about blue Vega
and the hierarchy of moving it so well
yeah yeah
you uh if you reuse that whole section
reference for something else
so the question oh yeah so yeah so okay
yeah so we didn't we didn't get ready so
it didn't disappear no no okay I didn't
change it
that's right yeah it did disappear
before and actually when we first
started working on drafting this it
wasn't in the law that we were using
because you had put it back in in
between so yeah like oh it's just gone
then then much too hard to say
you gotta buy more Green books yeah
we could put that law in this section
yeah
well we you just testified on it
yesterday or yesterday yeah
okay page 30.
so there is again just legal references
to from rsa193h to this chapter okay
so
but
this chapter refers to
well hold on you moved it to H right we
moved it from H so we combined e and H
together and so
um now all of this section is so the way
it kind of it was choppy before because
it talked about the accountability so
now all the accountability is at the
same piece and so now the oversight
committee is talking about the
accountability in this chapter in 193 e
right which consolidates e and H down
Foley thanks
okay
that's 30 31 same thing
um so I believe just from moved this
um we didn't know why the accountability
um the legislative oversight commission
for accountability was reviewing Sasa
number
um information about our unique people
identifier system we were just very
confused about the linkage of that in
general except for the fact that it kind
of falls under RSA 193e
because this the unique identifier
system is as we all know is a SAT I mean
maybe this was appropriate 15 years ago
when the identifier system was invented
but it we just feel like there was a lot
of Need for this yeah I think there's
still a question well
sorry thank you last year we even
you know realized or whatever had
happened that the the unique people
identifier hadn't hadn't been used in
charter schools or
esas or you know or they were and but
not in law that kind of thing and so I
don't think it's I it's definitely the
system is the system but who it applies
to
um is is an issue because somebody takes
state funded money then they should have
of people identifier right okay I
I mean a valid way to look at it if you
want that language back in I don't think
it does anything the Department's
completely impartial to that is it
someplace else I mean so we just we just
took it out of that because we didn't we
didn't we didn't know why the committee
we were doing it we've used the unique
pupil identifier no okay so it should
they're saying it should stay yeah yeah
I I I get that
that's part of the responsibility yes it
is
working
okay
why are we removing security there for a
long time
is it when we get
a data inventory and policies
Publications
I believe the reason we actually took
this out was because the RSA 1936 18966
already requires the department to issue
an annual report to members of the
legislators legislature
um so we didn't feel they needed to go
to this Commission in addition to
um this or the appropriate placement for
this law right here would be under RSA
1989 66 RSA 190 8966 requires a report
to already go to the State Board of
Education the governor the Senate
President the Speaker of the House the
chairperson of the senate committee
um and house over commissioner and doit
so we already felt like that was mostly
covered here in this this section of the
I kind of think it should stay there
simply because it's
fairly difficult
um to find the reports that go to the
different people uh whereas the
legislative oversight committee is
something that people will
be able to see and hear and
a lot of people at the same time review
it
so
that would be my suggestion this is the
is the our assassins part of the slds
yes
yeah I think this goes hand in hand with
the other
group assassin part
do we have any indication of how many
reports are done yearly on uh security
breaches I'm wondering like how what
level does this need to be at before it
comes to us
um we very rarely have any sort of
doesn't come to us
I'm sorry Mary really have any security
breaches and at this time they're mostly
handled by doit even if a school has a
breach they reach out to a doit they
don't even necessarily work with the
so this doesn't this doesn't take into
consideration like when
um an individual School District's I.T
is hacked and taken over and you know so
if a school district has an issue they
oftentimes reach out to the department
the department of information
Technologies and they have a data
specialist that they'll work with them
um but I don't know if they're following
when you look at 189 66 it says there's
an annual report provided what happens
if the report are the breaches today
is is any kind of report going to be
communicated regarding that breach today
so so this could also include breaches
um by you know not
directly by the by the department or a
um or a school but also by like the the
contractor who administers the state yes
challenge we've never had a breach from
our assessment vendor right right but
but clearly we have in statute and we
saw yesterday right so yeah or a couple
well I'm not on one on 189.66 it says
well like you said Rick we don't have to
solve it today but I think identifying
this is just a question concern area
Yeah question mark yeah
let's keep moving
um so this is just a new section
um we actually proposed to OLS creating
a whole new reporting section in general
but they didn't love that plan
um something that
this committee may want to consider is
having a reporting section of law that
refers to all reporting that is required
by School Districts I think it's very
hard that they have to flip through this
book and guess which reports are
supposed to to be submitted at various
different times but for the time being
OLS
um just uh came up with rsa193 k
and so uh this is where they moved uh
the slds language that was previously
one thing that we found was funny is we
all know what the word SAS it is but
there's no actual definition of sassadin
law so I thought that was should be
looks like Jen did catch a typo from OLS
those need to be assigned not assigned
back on page 32 does the definition of
Chartered Public School include
all of the
variations of Chartered Public Schools
so RSA 193 184b is all-encompassing
that's the charter school law so it
talks about conversions oh okay uh so
it's it's that of all charter schools
are there no no like like so you're
referencing back to 194b colon 1 to
Roman four
are you also addressing chart or gift
card Charter conversion School
that's not a charter well yeah it is so
Charter's conversion School locally
sponsored Charter and safe one responses
Charter are all contained in RSA 194b
yes and they're all subject to state
board approval correct right so yeah
yeah
so it's not a state board Charter
necessarily
um on page 34 the after your assassin
scholarship organization
um the definition of that I understand
that we're going to be putting it out
unless you rfps on uh maybe other
organizations that are going to be
dealing with that money other than the
children's scholarships organization and
they may not have scholarship
organization in their name so
word that we could use there rather than
the scholarship organization the RSA and
establishing education Freedom accounts
requires the use of a scholarship
organization so for that purpose of that
program scholarship organization has
already identified in law I do actually
want to say I believe this is a typo I
believe uh RSA
194e is actually Innovation school so it
um so we should make that as a
correction um but it specifically
requires scholar scholarship
organization so that's what that is
there okay because I thought I thought
it was
required this a scholarship organization
because it actually named the children's
it does not name the children's
Scholarship Foundation no it says it
requires the use of a scholarship
organization
so maybe I don't
well
I was going to think a non-profit
organization is unique people identifier
um
because we changed the word to Assassin
okay
does there have to be for folks to
really understand the change how they
can understand that change when they
look up unique people identifier yeah we
Define we defined it purposely I'd
actually say that people have a more
relationship with the word sasid number
than they have a unique of people
identifier so if you were to talk about
that people will do I don't know what
that is but if you said sassa Denver
like oh okay that and that was actually
part of the confusion because people all
the time would say I'm looking for the
law that establishes Sasa numbers where
is it you'd Google that you couldn't
come up with it and so okay
foreign
we're again using changing unique people
that are virus acid again we and then we
I don't know why this is out we talked
about how it's possibly why is it
removing
yeah so Nate and I talked about this we
think this is a mistake
um mistake this shouldn't be added back
it should be added over there
on page 36 e
when we went through this copy neither
Caitlin or I had removed that sections
we were surprised to see that was
so it just somehow it just disappeared
yes yeah there are multiple versions
that were sent to OLS and came back from
okay
12 36. yeah that's why I was going 36 37
but
so
I think anybody that searches for a Sasa
number is going to record somebody who's
searching for assassin number
so if I were to go in and search for
Assassin's number I would say Caitlin
Davis search for assassin number in our
system it wouldn't be you wouldn't be
able to do it anonymously it would
actually maintain a
um
like an audit like a technical trail
that
so the system is
just
I mean that's what it is
acid numbers it's a random number
generator so we have new students yeah
yeah
but we could we could change it to this
acid system or something like that yes
yes yes
right right and that that actually that
unique people identifier everywhere it's
in statute to different I believe we
tried to do that so what about the ball
on page 36 probably bottom line yes sir
yep that's a miss so yes I should say
[Applause]
unless they were concerned earlier about
people actually mucking with the random
Generate random number generator and
they wanted to make sure that uh if
anybody went into muck with it they
would know
including you know whatever programmers
yeah
but the generator so it's no longer
random
right
what is meant by Educational Services
that's a broad term
random number generator occurs again on
the next day I would have to just do a
control F on that one and uh double
check on those
we'll do that yeah it just in case they
were meaning the random number generator
you might want to check with the data
people
um
you're eliminating the person we
so that you want the whole system to be
all the other information that's
personally identified with both source
okay
right
please
so the whole idea about the staff is so
bad
information could be sent that it's not
personally identified right and so once
somebody has the the mapping of ass acid
and a name like Steve Woodcock well now
I know
so so the whole idea is to is to ensure
anonymity and protection of of
um personally pii so
thanks
it is relatively broad so the intent of
the paragraph is to ensure that things
outside of Education don't have an
ability to require individuals to
provide a sasset as a condition of doing
business
so education here in the term of
Educational Services is exempt because
SAS is often used in the provision of
many different kinds of educational
services but for example if a student
were applying for a job at a local
restaurant that restaurant would be
prohibited from requiring a sasset as a
condition of employment
but I agree the word or the term
Educational Services itself is not
I don't know
[Music]
so the cross of Medicare is is specific
to a federal law that will enable that
so we would have to apply for a waiver
so under this HHS would not get Sasa
numbers and would not collect Sasa
numbers it's the Department of Education
that would do that matching and maintain
that matching we would get a file that
had names and whatnot but but they don't
have any assassin information so it
wouldn't be affected by this
okay I had a question about that term
too Educational Services what are some
examples where you would give out the
student's name or they would be able to
get the student's name versus the
Assassin number or I mean what are some
examples
um specifically relative to the efas so
those the EFA needs assassin number to
be able to apply for a Sasa number they
need to okay so then the student of
course because the family name what
about the scholarship fund
so efas are managed by the scholarship
fund so yeah it does get the number and
the student name yes
because they are generating assassin
just like the schools are generating
Assassin of course they try to collect a
Sasa number
um and if they're unable to collect this
asset number then they'll go in and
generate assassin number in the exact
same way a school will and the
application goes to the scholarship fund
yes okay that's why they would need it
thank you Caitlin do you see any
any possible breach on that with the
with the Career Technical head that that
assassin because these kids are
you know working out in the field I
think you mentioned like a restaurant
that kind of you know where they're
actually through the school working
in an automotive shop or something
through career Ed is there any any way
they don't get sassered at all
they would end um and I don't
I don't know why they would need it okay
um well unless money was exchanged there
somehow right but it still that wouldn't
be necessarily the educational service
provider they wouldn't be the one that's
you know issuing the credit and whatnot
we could work on a definition of
Education Services maybe that's what
needs to be here okay just just as a
definition
I'm patreon right now I was talking with
Aaron yeah
37.
did you get a definition of uh Education
Services
it needs one
I actually
I'm sure that we do and I'm not sure
that we are the ones that took this out
we'll have to double check this it could
probably just put the legal reference
back in what is yeah okay yeah yeah I
don't know that it I don't know that
that needs to be removed I think just
putting back there I think maybe when
all of everything got moved around I
think that's potentially why that got
changed okay but yeah that makes sense
anything else on page 37
let's go at 38.
that looks pretty clean I really don't
because it doesn't we didn't think it
meant anything relative to this chapter
do we need to have something like you
know
we're trying to get them to talk with
each other
so that uh
but we don't think that this law enables
well they're sharing transcripts and the
Department of Education is not involved
in that but the community college system
with the
four-year system shares information
yeah that's good does it continue to
does that does that information contain
sacid are we still in Assassin but we're
taking it out right
why are we taking it out
uh we just we didn't know what the
purpose of it was
but it says it says like we're not
involved with their share it's
completely unrelated to the Department
of Ed and can people share anything of
this information doing dual concurrent
enrollment where we have high school
kids going to community college system
uh so all that information is done
locally yeah so all of that student
information is held by the local school
districts and that shared
um at the permission of students and
their families between the local school
district and the University Systems so
we're not a data pass through really in
any way for the University system or the
community college system and students
so and and this is relative to the
Community College and the university
system being able to talk to each other
so now we have without asking us for
profession funnel through the department
anymore goes directly to doesn't it to
the Community College systems so maybe
that's a cleanup we just we I have no
idea what this is saying and telling us
to do because we're not involved
we didn't think it needed to be here if
you want to leave it in here I suppose
you can but
it's kind of just words for the purpose
of being words
does does
either does does any um any school
Beyond any post-secondary
um receive information that has both
assassin and the student's name in it
we don't share that with not that I know
of
right because that's the part that's
confidential right you either have the
sassador you have the student name but
you never have both right correct yeah
yeah
um but but this is still this is just
the university system in the college
system right so if it involved assassin
then there's probably something I I
don't I don't even know that they use
it mostly them to use that but I I don't
think that they do I I don't know I just
I think it could probably come out you
know
you got unique people identified all
through this thing too
um
they're pursuing
yeah so the car in law has a mistake in
it
and both o and P
two lines four we have unique yeah
that's another one so does o on the
fourth line still has unique people well
it's all through that everywhere oh yeah
everyone
okay anything else uh
I guess we have no purpose for that part
there
had to be something something somewhere
What's um on page 40 I guess we're on
page 40. I don't know notwithstanding
RSA 14 colon 49.
the department didn't add that in OLS
added that in so I'm not sure what that
reference is for I don't know it's not
in our law book I don't think it's not
yeah yeah so I don't know what that
legal reference is anybody has a laptop
or
important
genocide so yeah I'm guessing that the
law probably on this on establishing
study committees Maybe
14 49 maybe a processor procedure or was
or
is
1449 what limits the size and
membership of a committee representative
Damon is just for you yeah that's I
think that's so it's saying that forget
about that you can
oh and that's you know what it's because
OLS actually they were concerned with
this because it has more than the number
of people that you're supposed to have
and they're saying that but because it
was established before that and is in
law it's all set but going forward even
if it's established after you'd still be
able because it's in law
I'm not going to fight with the drafting
attorneys
yeah so
no but that's what that's getting at
yeah
amen so we made no changes to the
okay
do we have to finish this today can we
I think that's you know not much left in
there I think it's good yeah yeah we've
thanks
mostly
keeping kind of things
yeah I'll just I'll remind the committee
kind of how this came about so
um
in the summer slash fall
um the department
so about the department the division my
division division of Education analytics
and resources inherited the assessment
program it was previously run by the
division of learner support
um that's something that historically
was together at the Department of
Education was separated for a period of
time and then brought back together it
really makes sense for it to be together
there's a lot of data exchange there's a
lot of the same understanding of
programs so that was one of the pieces
that kind of brought this about
um to the second piece I kind of brought
this about is in the 2223 biennium
budget the Department of Education was
given a position to start overseeing
State accountability so previously all
of the state accountability positions
that are removed from the Department of
education's budget and had have been for
several years and so we received one
position and so would that person began
doing that work and putting that
together for the Department we really
did a deep dive into the law and said
all right well you know this makes sense
this doesn't make sense and then part of
this was um
so
um there were two relatively large
legislative changes that were made that
were had not been implemented or tried
or tried to be implemented by the
department until this time and so
um those changes were the change of the
state pbas the performance-based
accountability system from going from
something that was designated in state
law to um tying it to the federal
accountability system
um so that happened in 2017 and 18. so
even though the law change in the
department hadn't implemented because we
didn't have to have the staff to do that
and then the other legislative change
that happened was the change from
a school being required to demonstrate
that they're providing an adequate
education through either ibas or pvas to
having to demonstrate it through both
imass and pbas so that's when we kind of
sat down and tried to do all of that
work with the with the combination of
the assessment
um working this uh assigned to my
division and then also that position and
so we've done all that work in in
culmination or together and really come
up with all right well there are some
things that just made no sense about the
law or something that just were just
very unclear we were kind of confused by
or we thought that there were sections
of law that weren't necessarily doing
anything
um and so actually I went back and read
my notes and I saw it after our
committee meeting last week and I saw
the word competency and who are very
concerned that the word competency was
deleted but my notes had said that we
didn't actually use the word competency
throughout this so that's kind of where
all this came from so it was kind of a
pet project of Nate and I to try to get
ourselves a law that actually made sense
that we could Implement
um with the limited resources that we
have at the department right now to best
leverage our federal funds to kind of do
some of this work and then our state
funds but then also be able to implement
A system that we could communicate to
the schools that so that's really where
we are here at the department
um we've been implementing the
assessment program this spring Nate has
done a ton of work with that um and we
felt that it's gone very well
um and we are going to begin to do some
of the asset uh the accountability work
this fall um we intend to anyways
assuming this enabling legislation will
pass
um and we should hopefully kind of start
rolling that out and communicating with
the schools so we have some uh technical
assistance advisory that we would like
to provide to the schools this spring
letting them know about what the
accountability schedule for the fall is
but we it's kind of contingent on
knowing where the committee wants to go
with some of this work do you have this
report I can't see that you can't see
um this has within it
um text of current statutes not
um
it is just kind of the first few pages
that one right there and then and
um you know where the
three chapters are repealed and
reenacted or 193h is just repeal and
with those sections that I didn't locate
within the new versions of the chapters
um and I just pasted those sections
again at the end in their articles
so you don't have a copy of that I I
don't with me the first part is the
and it's continued here continued on the
next page
performance-based accountability system
there's areas which have been
Incorporated but others that are just
there's holes
um
maybe you need to have a copy of this
because there's about
yeah it must be about six or seven pages
here on areas which are not included did
you already know well because I can I
so there's a lot that was removed only
because it was duplicative of the
federal law there were a lot in the
federal law that just was pasted into
the state law and we Nate and I felt
that was not necessary
um so if that
if that's the kind like I know first
example in College and Career Readiness
indicators were listed in the state law
well they're compliant with the federal
program so if we were to add a new
College and Career Readiness indicator
to the federal program in the federal
plan now all of a sudden the state law
is not going to tie to that so that's
but you know this page right here which
has all those indicators of a delivery
delivering an opportunity for an
adequate education
as a Litany of of areas which uh we get
information back on the number of kids
doing this the number of percentage of
kids doing that number of kids that do
the ASVAB it just no those are the yeah
those are the College and Career
editingness indicators that um so we
refer back to the federal law on that so
all that we refer back to these I look
at these all the time right and all of
those are still there and we will
collect all of that information they're
all part of the performance-based
accountability system
so so in order to when we are looking at
CSI designations for example College of
kubernetes indicators are part of the
CSI determination at this at the high
school level and so we would be
collecting and determining that
information
um that is part of the whole the whole
definition and in our federal our
federal plan
and so we agree we're not we're not
trying to eliminate that at all
I think part of the problem of not
putting those in here is that a lot of
us just look in the state laws to see
what the state laws say and we don't
necessarily have easy access to the
federal laws or know even where to look
for the particular thing so if
if it's laid out in here
well and and so to mitigate your concern
we specifically have added references
into the state plan and defined what the
state plan is before there wasn't some
of that information and we felt that
that was really important to have a
definition of Essa and what smnn and the
definition of esea and the plan and and
whatnot so if
so if we just have this
are there sufficient references so that
anything that's in state law and that's
in federal law that we would need to
know this would have references to that
so we would be able to find that we
foreign
yeah so that's all the stuff that was
so this report right here is a
requirement of not just the feds but
also the state correct
so if we as a state are saying we want
to have this information
for every school district
where would we go you know where would
we go to get this information
are you collecting this information we
are yes
yes
now if we take that out is there going
to be any information there at the
districts and say we're not required to
do that now no well so right now the
state law says you're required to do
everything that's in the in the plan
so in the plan in the plan not in
statute no it says in the plan well the
so our concern really was that we didn't
want one changing without the other
change and we kind of there was a while
that we were living with that even
though the department wasn't
implementing it and we were having we
had
State CSI oh sorry we had State local
education Improvement schools or
something like that we had cities this
has nothing to do with that though this
is inadequacy so that that was was
inadequacy before yeah because we want
that information from everybody it's an
indicator of having an opportunity for
an adequate education right and and so
we we the department in 2017 or 18 we
actually tied our adequacy law to the
federal plan
so that so wait so the list of data and
it's a pretty extensive list of data
there that's all required to be
collected by federal statute as well and
that's what the performance-based
accountability system is so in the state
statute when you look at P bass at the
two different parts of accountability
ibas and bass pbas is that collection of
data indicators there and that's all
detailed out on the state Essa plan so
regardless of whether we list it here in
the stature or not we the department is
required to collect all that data under
federal statute as well what we've done
here is we've we've tied that list of
data and indicators to the pbas so by
telling districts you have to meet the
performance-based accountability system
we're saying you have to provide all of
this federally required data and show us
that you're meeting certain benchmarks
and expectations when it comes to
measuring the performance of a school
so it's in a way it's not that it's it's
missing or gone we still have to collect
the data no matter what we've just
identified here in the statute that an
adequate education is tied to pbas and
pbas is a collection of these indicators
which is in the state as a plan and I
think to Caitlyn's point one of the
problems is when we list out indicators
in the state law and we have the
indicators listed in federal law we have
the indicators in our state asset plan
anytime one of those changes now we're
out of compliance across three different
areas so that's part of the problem
we're trying to fix here is by
referencing the performance-based
accountability system and our federally
required data which matches this list
then if the feds at some point change
that or if the state decides we need to
submit a new state plan because some
other statute has changed the list can
stay consistent but the data will always
be collected by the department
but you see when we were had to study
Commission on funding back
and I can remember Val who was fanchak
when we were looking at the Bia the
business industry Association we're also
looking at Career Technical education
and he opened up his his book here
and he said look at this this is what
one two three four different places that
mentioned CTE underneath adequacy
and under these indicators right here
that is identified but if this doesn't
appear in statute and it's in an s a
plan
it's not going to be captured by a
person like Val who was trying to
justify in that conversation we had why
we should be funding CTE more
or through adequacy
um so I it's to me where it is in
statute it's easy to find it's there and
people see it but if it's an Essa
I I never pull this up so the the
problem with doing that and having them
listen separately is if there's changes
and now we have slightly different
versions of each one now we're going to
have slightly different lists of schools
that are low performing schools so we're
going to have Federal low performing
schools and then we're going to have
state low performing schools even though
they're the same students in the same
measurements and same metrics
um so that's when we tie them all
together that's what we are trying to
avoid because we didn't want to have
schools that were not finding adequate
education but seemed fine federally or
schools that seemed failing federally
but were considered providing an
adequate education so I don't know what
the answer to that is
um as far as you know making sure that
they all shift together
um but
because if we change one and then we you
know there's a whole process of changing
our federal plan we you have to ask you
know permission for the feds it takes
months on end for them to review but
there has been like a lot of a lot of
conversations around for example those
College and Career ready indicators and
if we should be changing those or not
and then so what happens if now we just
have a stateless of College and Career
Readiness indicators and then a
federalist
but isn't it our responsibility as a
state to decide what it is that we want
and not just uh whatever the federal
government says and if we take it out
then it's just whatever the federal
government says and we no longer have
that say as far as we may want
stronger recommend you know we may have
want to do something stronger or
whatever than the federal government is
um
you do have that Authority as a state
but that is not what the intention of
the state law currently is the state law
the intention is to have them tied
together and that's also partially
because of resources that the Department
of Education because we don't have
anybody that's paid with State funds to
do I know you have this accountability
work and so without having those
staffers we're basically getting a
two-for-one deal we're paying somebody
with a federal money to do the
calculation but we're using it for State
purpose as well so we're going to need
somebody to run a state list and a
federalist simultaneously going forward
so that's another concern
all right thank you
so
so uh you know along you know I I
understand why your intention here and I
think I think it makes sense but um but
at the same time you know I wouldn't
want to see us lose
um data collection because maybe a
change is made at the federal level that
no longer collects certain data because
they don't see it necessary for all 50
states and um and maybe in New Hampshire
we we want to see it necessary and and
maybe that's worth having a debate
every few years when the um when the
when the um the federal
where when there are changes made at the
federal level whether we want to adopt
those changes or whether we want to Inc
you know include some of the things that
we have historically collected
um and and you know I guess right here
we're we're you know based on what you
know you you've said that what we're
eliminating is what contained at the um
at the US Ed you know in US Ed rules but
um but we won't know when those us rules
change because we don't have a usn rule
law book you know so it's actually it's
a little bit more in the control of New
Hampshire than that and I probably I
think I did a poor job explaining it the
first time so the whatever we write into
our state Essa plan is what we're held
to by the federal statute and so
different states may have different
lists of data and indicators and so it's
only if our state plan change like if we
decide New Hampshire decides to rewrite
our state plan that's when that list of
data and indicators would change it
wouldn't necessarily be a change
initiated by the federal government and
when we talk I think there's a section
in the legislative oversight committee
that talked about the performance
targets so this list of data in the
state Esso plan has Associated
performance targets which can be
reviewed and approved by that
legislative oversight committee so my
guess is there would be some involved if
any kind of change were to be
recommended to the state as a plan
they'd probably be involvement by this
legislative body in terms of any of
those changes
so in that sense we're lucky because the
feds can't just come in and change that
list we defined that list and we took
essentially what was in our state
statute and we stuck it into our state
plan and that's why they match is we we
did an intentional effort to make the
match if that if that's helpful yeah I
mean I think that's I think that's
helpful Nate but um you know
but but I I I I think losing them from
the Essa plan isn't in statute the Essa
plan is is is what was what the is
developed by the department in
consultation with the um with the
oversight committee I think that was one
of the things
um in the in the list uh but having them
in statute I think
I I think I I don't want to speak for
Rick but I think you're
you're concern is that you you you you
want them in
having them in statute has some meaning
well I think we got to be accountable
not just to Essa but we got to be
accountable to as the legislative body
responsible for developing and
identifying what an adequate education
is
we are responsible to the people of the
state to provide that and these are the
indicators that we are delivering them
there's got to be a place where we can
reference these indicators other than in
a federal application or plan for Essa
so somewhere there's this stuff's you
know it took us years to put this
together it used to be much shorter we
could probably make a list that's twice
that length and indicator so I'm sure
but but you know I can just remember
Mary Gile talking we got to have
something about expulsion and suspension
that's in there
um
I I just I I I'd hate to see this
disappear and I hate that then as a
state legislature to hand this over to
the State Board of Education
to make that decision based upon
requirement that you have to report to
the feds it seems to me that we should
be able to do both
right and and if you know and I
I mean obviously there's a lot of Court
action right now and and the school
funding formula may change I'm sure
we'll change again down the road but she
may change totally yeah and and you know
we've you know we we
um sponsored a bill co-sponsored a bill
um
last year that took into consideration
attendance rates and and um number of or
percentage of graduating high school
students and things like that so being
able to reference some statutory
language you know in a school funding
formula uh I I think has has
significant Merit because now the
funding formulas require requiring those
metrics as well as the statute that
they're referencing
um
foreign
I'm absolutely fine with building an
actual State accountability arm of the
department but the legislature just
really needs to realize that that's a
commitment they need to make and have
people that are designated to do that
work for State purposes rather than just
for federal purposes and that's a
separate conversation that we're not
we're trying to not have as part of this
bill but that's a real concern is we
don't have designated people and staff
at the department to oversee State
accountability and state and ensure
schools are providing an adequate
and see we we went that route too when
we were doing our assessments too we
didn't have the people we didn't have
the test for social studies so we bagged
that down to the local level
you do it local
um so it's I guess that I'm trying to
maintain program and it seems that we're
we've always designed our program around
the dollar that's available to support
program so it's not program budgeting
we're just budgeting based upon a
limited dollar and I hate to see us then
start developing our policy or our
statutes based upon limited dollar uh we
should have had we should set that bar
where we want to set the bar and I agree
we got to fund it if we want that
information and that data but I I think
it'd be wrong to take this stuff out of
law right now uh I think I think we make
a dreadful mistake and maybe not pay for
it now but maybe three or four years
down the road we would and then the
other thing too is there's some of the
federal information that's in the law in
the state law but not all of it so
there's probably needs to be more
comprehensive information in the state
law so the state law is not prescriptive
enough to really get to where we need it
to be so probably all of the state law
really needs or all of the state plan
needs to be in law
yeah some of this on the second page
talks about level one two three and four
that's fed stuff there but we use it we
use it and to determine
could it best be served in minimum
standards in the ad rules
resist serves as a guidance of all the
data collection
if it were in the Ed rules
which is sort of what you follow to make
sure your
would that solve anything to to make it
in rules I I mean it it's I mean rules
are just as inflexible as a law I would
say actually as of lately I think the
law is let is more flexible than the
rules just given the process okay notice
the department collect this data right
now
um the indicators uh we yeah we have a
form and it's a Sasa number one two
three four five and we ask the schools
how many of those indicators each
so would you not be able to do that if
we left those left leaves in no oh we're
required to do it by the federal law so
we're going to be doing it regardless
so then what is the additional money
that you're talking about if you're
doing it anyways we have nobody that's
doing it for the state side of things so
realistically if you're going to have
two different systems two different
accountability systems then there should
be some people that are focusing on the
state stuff and some people that are
what are those superintendents say do
they have an opinion on that do you know
on I'm aware of those ones keeping this
in statute versus not well I mean the
superintendents have to do it regardless
because they know they have to do it for
Essa so they don't care whether they
didn't say anything but I'm guessing
they don't care whether they have to do
it the difference from the state or the
federal they still have to do it yeah
it's not like it's not like the work
changes for them
I I don't know how to resolve this mess
that this information
is needed I believe
and it says right here that Department
of Education shall development in a
reasonable schedule to collect the
reporting of data required by the state
and federal law
now if we're going to take the state out
of the business here
we might as well just let the feds tell
us how to do everything
now I'm going kind of extreme there but
you know I understand there's a lot of
dollars come down from the feds and I
understand that what seventy percent of
your staff over there are paid through
federal dollars I don't know what the
percentage off my topic yeah
so
um
and I I think that we can't just let the
State Board of Education start
developing this stuff without having it
the legislature involved with it I mean
I I can tell you that Nate and I believe
that there should be a strong State
accountability system and you know we
would love to designate as many
resources to it as possible
um this is work the department should be
doing and would like to be doing and
we're trying to implement the law the
best we possibly can given the resources
that we have to do it
um but we have a lot of opinions on what
we can we could be doing
um first and what we should be doing and
there's there's better ways to do all of
it
so if if we're collecting it anyways and
if it is virtually the same
would not the same reports can't work
for both so my point right now yes today
we can do a two for one but the second
there's a slight change we can't do a
two for one anymore and this kind of
thing is changing frequently I mean
there very well could be so if this bill
isn't going to pass a right now and it
goes then we start doing something again
next fall or whatever or a year out and
we might have changes and we might need
to do different different systems and
that's what we're trying to avoid
without because we don't have adequate
resources to run multiple systems
thank you and you're talking about
changes in the in the federal rules for
the plan or the or the state or the
state plan so I I think because what a
good one is is we've had a lot of
conversations about we should go back to
the field and work with the field and
look at the college career I need this
indicator list which is that list that
representative Vlad just brought up
um there's a lot of you know
superintendents have brought to us and
said oh well what about this or why
isn't this on the list and we agree the
list was put together in 2015 and it
probably could be looked at since we're
almost eight years down the road on that
um but uh so if that were to happen we
would work with stakeholders to
potentially change that list we would
get approval from the U.S Department of
Education we would modify our data
collection but now we'll have the state
plan or the state law that requires us
to collect the old list and then the
federal collecting the new list so we'll
have two separate data collections that
are required to be done by the school
districts and then we'll need kind of
people to monitor both of those separate
data Collections and then two different
designations we know we're going to be
doing a CSI designation for the federal
level based on a federalist and a CSI
designation on the state level but date
so you know one concrete example is this
past legislative cycle there was
requirements added in around the FAFSA
uh where schools now have to make sure
that students are filling out the FAFSA
and the last data point out here letter
O under that list of data indicators is
the number of percentage of graduating
high school students provided in-person
assistance in completing the FAFSA so
those were all new requirements added to
State Statute but when you look at the
accountability plan under the pbas pbas
doesn't include that language because we
pull that from our state as a plan so
that's an instance right now where
there's one data requirement in the
state plan tied to adequate education
but our accountability system is the CSI
school system which does not include
that data requirement so each time one
of these areas changes either we have to
go and change the back end of it or we
have to somehow make the two systems
comply with each other
um and that's that's where the
implementation side of it gets difficult
for the Department because
it there there's two systems essentially
the state and federal system and it's to
Caitlyn's point I think the more one
changes versus the other one the more
we're going to be running to
simultaneous but different systems and
we'll have to have multiple sets of
staff to do those
right right but but you know again you
know the um
you know the federal accountability is
you know there there's about what 200
million dollars that comes along from
from the federal government
um to put that in context a billion
dollars from the state of New Hampshire
and two billion dollars from local
property taxpayers so I think the state
accountability
part is really assuring
um that that our own taxpayers money is
being used in a way that's um that's you
know yielding good results and and and I
think our school funding formula uh
hopefully is migrating in a direction I
think we made some very strong changes
to it um this year in the the house
budget Senate doesn't mess around with
it well we're going to make sure of that
and uh and that that that moves Us in
that direction uh as well but um but in
order to to to be able to do that we're
going to need to make sure that we're uh
collecting the information we need to uh
to not just not just be accountable to
the lowest performing you know schools
but to all schools
um you know across the state so so you
know that that sort of uh where are we
at the five percent cut or the 7 percent
cut or whatever it was the other um
Monday when we were talking about this
um you know I I don't think that cuts it
for the um you know for the state and um
and so I I'd be I'd be very
um I I
you know maybe maybe not all of this
needs to remain in statute but maybe a
lot of it does
I mean a lot of it is it's it's
information it's gives us feedback
for example like the concurrent dual
enrollment indicator where we want to
know the number of kids that passed at
least one course concurrent dual
enrollment now I know that may be
difficult to attain senior we're now
working with the Community College
pretty closely on that the another
indicator right down here where you know
the number of kids that are completing
uh International Baccalaureate program
or a AP course
so
department when we work with the
legislature in 2017 to tie the two
together was so we had the same system
for both I don't think it makes sense to
have two very slim similar but slightly
different systems they should be exactly
the same or we should have just a state
accountability system and maybe the
decision of this committee is that we
should go in and say what is important
for the purpose of State accountability
and actually design a state
accountability system that is not just a
shadow system of the February honest
with you Caitlyn when I looked at that
back in 2017 my intent was to get
information back which would let me know
whether we are delivering this adequate
education
I
my I had less intent and I probably
didn't have any intent regarding the the
Essa stuff the stuff that goes to the
feds I was more concerned that we are
getting back some measure that says that
we're we're providing that opportunity
for an adequate education I think if we
take these indicators out we're going to
you know
I don't know where I'll end up it's all
going to be an Essa plan nobody's ever
going to see it
and I think that we just want to
remember too the only thing we're
talking about here is a College and
Career Readiness indicators for seniors
in high school we're not talking about
we're we're not talking about uh
comprehensive accountability system so
we should talk about what it means for
all grades and accountability looks like
for all things it was underneath
adequacy underneath the topic delivery
of an adequate education
to me that says yes career Readiness is
that's something that came out of the
era back then 2015-17
started with Ross cattell pumping that
stuff and then here we are now uh uh I I
I I just you know I'm fearful that if we
don't do maintain some of this uh does
the the federal program want to know the
number of kids go off the military
experience
the mirror of the federal program right
now this all these things in here are
weird when we wrote this bill in 2017 we
copied and pasted the federal plan into
this so you get the information right so
why are we taking out a statute because
what we what we didn't want is visit is
what's in the plan to be slightly
different from the state that's that's
the only reason why we didn't want there
to be too too slightly different lists
one a federalist and one estate list we
there's not a difference right now no
no no we would ideally we would never
rewrite it again and it would just
continue to be a system that's
supporting the field
um we did make some indentments and
changes to it over the past two years as
a result of the pandemic
um because there was one year where we
didn't run the state assessment there
was one year where we ran the assessment
but there was limited accountability but
those were addendums based upon the
circumstances of the pandemic outside of
that we we have the discretion as a
state to determine when we want to
rewrite that plan
and then the funding is tied to that
right through American Rescue and
Recovery Act whatever do you know if
there's a Sunset date for that
so I don't know about the recovery funds
specifically but all title funds are
tied to that Essa plan so schools
receiving one two three four through
Title IX all those funds are tied to us
fulfilling our obligations of the state
but I would think we would want to have
the state be the one who takes
precedence and any new statutes that we
pass be the ones that that the plan be
changed based on our statutes not our
statutes based on the plan
that
might not be allowable because there
might be a federal statute that would
change that would require our plan to
change so we would have to change our
federal plan based on any federal law
even if it were to conflict in the state
law I would consuming assuming we would
want to continue to participate in the
federal programs
and so I know Caitlin has talked a
little bit about resources so the bureau
that I've receive is the Bureau of
assessment and accountability in terms
of positions I have one person in that
Bureau that does accountability so that
person's job is to oversee the Essa
Federal plan that we have for CSI TSI
and ATS schools and that's part of why
we mirrored the state accountability
with the state Essa plan because we have
one staff member of the department that
must oversee both
and so we don't want to have two
different competing systems that have to
yeah
that's in the bill that's an HP too
a data analyst alone is not required is
not necessary so I'm just saying yeah so
let me kind of I can talk about the
people that are paid by the federal
funding to do some of this work so we
have um several staffers that do the
data collection side of things and
they're known as i4c help desk folk and
and they are on the phone 24 7 with
schools collecting data and whatnot we
then have data
um or data warehouse Architects that
warehouse all the data do all the
matching do the different do all the
different calculations we then have a
contractor which are hoping to have a
position to replace the contractor
should considerability in cell that does
all of the calculations is in charge of
all the business rules actually sorry
two contractors that do that work and
then we have at least one internal
position that oversees the reporting
side of things we then have another
contractor that that all this is all
paid by federal funding that oversees
all of the federal report cards that are
required to be put out where we put all
of this data out
um and I'm sure I'm forgetting a couple
a couple but we're talking about quite a
bit of Staff resources are paid by
we don't need to fix it today I was just
going to say we don't need to fix it
today
um and if this stays in the law it's not
going to be the end-all be-all you can
put it back in it's just a little bit
messy and we have potential issues by
going forward by leaving it this way if
there are changes
um because the department will probably
begin to work with the field about
changing the College and Career
Readiness indicators at a minimum going
forward and potentially some other CSI
School designations but they're there
probably should be somebody some more
staff at the department focused on state
accountability I I don't know that
most people would disagree with that
statement if it's an important
work that the Department's doing how
many people you're talking about
we've got to figure out what to say if
we were to have a state accountability
system that looks different than a
federal we would have to see what that
system looks like
and what's your average cost person 140
you'd have to add access access
for Ells as well in the list
I added my notes we talked about CNS
Readiness um yeah CNC Readiness and
access
for ell was it your intent to add that
to that list
or just my notes what page are you
looking at uh on the same delivery of an
adequate education is still on the list
so that is that is a part of the federal
accountability system it is in there
yeah when when we look at this
particular list here this is relative to
just the College and Career ready data
so the CCR indicator but the Essa plan
is much more Broad and there's several
sections in there that refer to access
testing and English language proficiency
yeah so it is part of the larger system
so we have to have as a minimum what the
Federal
guidelines are if we want the money but
we could add
over above that if we want more but if
we had this other person would they be
able to own with
could they use all of the federal stuff
that we have and just look at whatever
yeah it's hard to talk about a
theoretical accountability system
without saying what it may or may not
look like but potentially
um I anytime there's duplication we try
to be as efficient as possible with
duplication
um and duplicative efforts to collect
data and whatnot we we've we've even
tried to do it two for one when we were
talking about cynics we said oh should
uh Civics be a college degree Readiness
indicator because we're just literally
trying to do a two for one with that one
um but that's just not you know what
we're doing so
I think we could go round and round for
a long time since we have on this I just
it seems to me that if there is no need
to update the asset plan or you don't
foresee it because it's been approved
that we wait and see moving forward I
mean maybe in six months they'll be I
just do I think I know what you're
trying to do and it makes sense yeah I I
think the thing coordinate does we
probably didn't put enough of the slang
like
there's not enough of the Essa language
that's in the state law that you could
do it without reading the plan so
there's probably
more information that needs to be added
in the state law to actually be able to
implement it if you wanted to be able to
do it independently of the federal plan
so it was we yeah it was just too short
essentially
on this uh sheet going beyond the
indicators that uh Jen's provided us uh
I'm looking at that portions which deal
with performance-based accountability
system and then performance-based School
accountability system verification
process all that's been left out
which one would be G1 well I'll look at
page nine the last page
the commissioner shall work with school
officials and faculty from selected
schools to implement the performance
Space School accountability program and
to develop a data collection system
which will allow schools to easily
report results to the department for
analysis and Reporting it's all the
responsibilities of the commissioner
well I I think that this language is
written prior to
the existence of I think this was the
enabling language that allowed the
department to collect the data
collection or to to establish the data
collection systems that we have right
now and so we didn't feel like this was
necessary because we already have those
systems in place so the the
uh we already have those I I mean if you
want to put it back in there what
happens if we change and we do something
different
um
would we have to reference back to this
to say what the commissioner
responsibilities are
for future purposes if we're not using
it right now maybe we will in the future
I've been looking last time we
so most of the system
and I I kind of hate to keep saying it
but that the performance-based school
accountability system the pbas system is
all detailed really extensively in that
state plan and so that's why some of
these sections were pulled out because
much of that is in the plan itself so
when we when you look at the bill as
proposed now the pbas system identifies
CSI TSI and ATS schools as being those
underperforming schools that are not
demonstrating the criteria for
inadequate education but the process by
which those schools are identified is
all detailed out in the state asset plan
and the current sections of Statute here
are more vague than the specifics that
are actually in the state Essa plan so I
can understand the concern of well it
looks like we're pulling that section
out and we're not replacing it with
anything but what's actually happening
is we're taking those sections out
because the really detailed language of
what the system looks like what the
checks and balances are what the data
collection is is all in that state Essa
plan which is you know really it's about
a hundred plus pages of you know the
actual process the department follows
for identifying those underperforming
schools
so they're sort of almost like two
branches that I feel like we could go
here a little bit is you know what we've
tried to do is take out a lot of the
vagueness in current statute and
reference CSI TSI and ATS schools is the
ones that are the schools that aren't
meeting you know all of those Benchmark
targets that we've set in our plan
the other thing we could do is if we
want that level of specificity in the
law we almost have to take what's in our
current asset plan and put that into the
law but again you're talking about over
100 pages of really detailed out you
know accountability system and programs
that are in that plan
and that's where we get a little bit
hesitant because if you detail them in
both places anytime one changes the
other one does so it's kind of those are
the two paths I I think from an
implementation perspective you know when
we look at okay how do we go to our
staff how does the department work with
the field to make sure they understand
what is the accountability system we
want to make sure we're all talking
about the same accountability system
and we can detail that anywhere we can
detail that in State Statute we can
detail that in the asset plan and I
think that's sort of up to this body to
determine we just don't end up in a
situation where we have competing
accountability systems existing in both
and then trying to explain that to the
field
this works I thought
the state came up with State Statute
which was kind of more General
and then
the department and whatever rules get
developed about how to implement the
state statute and so your plan would
have to follow State Statute so taking
State Statute out
then you no longer have the authority to
even do your plan do you I mean doesn't
the statute have to stay there so that
you can do your plan and that's what so
the there are still the sections of the
performance-based accountability system
in this bill that's being proposed so
it's not being removed what we've done
is we've cleaned it up and the language
that is now being proposed in this bill
references the performance-based
accountability system and it's so our
state statute says schools must follow
the performance-based accountability
system which is in the state Essa plan
and we've defined both of those things
in statute so then when a school looks
at that they go oh I'm required by New
Hampshire State Statute to follow pbas
pbas is in the state asset plan and so
you pull that state asset plan up and
there's your 120 pages of school
accountability that they have to do we
have to do it regardless because it's a
federal requirement so no matter what
the state statute says we're going to do
the state as a plan what we try to do is
make sure that the the state statute
said because we're doing accountability
and because the department and schools
already have to do the state as a plan
let's mirror our state and federal
accountability and when we wrote the
state plan we took all the indicators
from State Statute and put that in there
so this list of data that includes
things like CTE indicators suspension
and expulsion data attendance rates
that's all in the state's plan
and now the statute just says schools
and Department you have to do the state
plan
if so so the authority is there it's
just not spelled out in detail the
system in both places
yeah so
the Essa plan is I remember we went
through it piece by piece and voted on
it and I just noticed I was trying to
find it and I just noticed that there's
modifications that have been requested
by the Department of Education
um on the asset plan and yet that hasn't
come through the legislature as far as I
know is that is that
not what's supposed to happen or why why
is that happening as well
so I believe those are the the addendum
requests that we had made as a result of
the the pandemic um those are the most
recent changes that we would have made
to the plan
um and those we had to make because the
state plan is based off of three years
worth of data and because we didn't run
the state assessment system during that
first year of the pandemic and then we
had limited data the second year we
didn't have three years worth of data to
hold schools accountable to so we had
applied for some limited changes to the
state plan with the feds so that we
weren't held accountable to three years
of data when we didn't have three years
worth of data it was uh I believe it had
been put out for public comment at the
time when it was submitted and we had to
have a approval through the governor's
office as well so I know it was vetted
through the governor's office it never
came through the legislative branch
which seems like if we're the ones that
are doing the
statutes for Education should come
wouldn't it seem that way
absolutely and especially if the um the
the data that you're collecting is
conditioned on by what's listed in the
plan if changes can be made to the plan
unilaterally or without legislative
oversight then what do we know what what
we're losing or what what we no longer
have have access to
um yeah and I will say we didn't change
the system at all we just requested an
ability to push the system the timeline
of the system forward by two years right
right no I appreciate that but I think I
think what what representative Tanner's
concern is is that is that changes could
be made without without legislative
involvement and and there's you know
what certainly one of the things I think
we learned in the school funding
commission was the importance of of
um you know years of of data that has
been consistently collected because then
you can really look at Trends and and
and you know and develop
um you know different
um you know mechanisms for um for
funding and accountability and if you've
got you know you know breaks in that
data because something's no longer being
collected because the Essa plan has has
changed then um then you know then some
of that data may may no longer be
relevant for um uh for future news uh so
I I
you know want to want to sort of tread
carefully on what it is we'd be losing
by taking taking some of these or taking
all these out or taking some of them out
and know exactly what um what
the legislature might want to continue
to collect for current and future you
know State accountability I think
Caitlyn I think you you laid out the
right question is what do we want to
really be doing here having a state
accountability plan and a federal
accountability plan or one plan or both
plans or you know or what is it yeah and
I think that you know when we did this
in 2018 I didn't see that was 2018 since
that I think the intent was to tie the
two together and it sounds like
potentially that was maybe a mistake but
if if that's what we're saying that if
we want to run two separate systems it
was a mistake for the department at the
yeah I'm not I'm not saying it was a
mistake to tie
um time together back then it probably
got us off to a good start on um uh on
that but but
yeah but you know I don't necessarily
think that that state accountability
should absolutely follow Federal
accountability because I think you know
you're sort of being accountable for
different things and um and staying
accountability is a lot greater I mean
there's certainly a lot more dollars
involved at the state local level than
there are at the federal level and um uh
and then you know as as Rick mentioned
right at the top we may want to use some
of this data for other other purposes
too whether that's at the um at K-12 or
at
um you know programs with the community
college system
um it sounds like we're fighting that
tell them yeah yeah
look where we are yeah
kind of describe where we're at some of
those
yeah I'd like to ask one question go
ahead Oliver
part of the problem for someone like me
who's not been in this system at all is
trying to figure out to whom do I go to
find the answer to my question and it
seems to me that much of what we're
looking and talking about would be
made easier to think if we had an index
of some sort that tells me that you used
to keep this money over here but now
it's kept over there but part of it is
sent off to somebody else and there's no
road map to find out what happened so
how do we have what I call
accountability which is an ultimate
accounting and this system calls
accountability well we have a process
for that
and I don't see that the is the end
point in the process and so it's very
hard to follow not having participated
with you in this exactly
what went where and why and what was
this been for and what was the result
and how all that gets together and
you're talking about well we sent that
to these people we sent that to those
people they can tell you what happened
to it but
without asking you if the two of you
retired we'd have to shut down the state
government
it's nice
thanks not proposing an easy out
but nonetheless you you can't buy
dilemma but I do I and we've had similar
conversations I think with community
members with parents with you know
superintendents and principals and
what's the best way of communicating out
all the data that the department does
collect I think one thing that's
important to understand is this is a
relatively short list of data indicators
we're talking about here it's a through
o
um if you go into the I report system we
publish a report card annually for every
school and every District that probably
has over a hundred different pieces of
data related to each of those individual
schools and districts so it's a it's a
snapshot here and I think when we talk
about building accountability systems if
you're talking about really looking at
it from start to finish you have to
figure out what is it that we want want
to hold people accountable too you know
most most of this data we're talking
about here is really high school level
data but we're reporting on on data that
includes things like the number of
classes and percentages of students
being taught by early career teachers
versus experienced teachers versus
teachers that are teaching outside of
their subject area all the different
percentages and breakdowns of all
different subgroups of students and
their educational progress through K-12
so there's a huge amount of data that
the department collects presents and
reports out on on those school and
district report cards and part of that
is the accountability system right one
one is public transparency of having all
that data but the other part is you know
what are the sections that we're going
to say these are the the core tenants
that we're gonna you know have schools
report on that is tied to an
accountability system where we say okay
what are the schools that are that are
underperforming where are the schools
that need the most assistance how can we
better direct things like state and
federal dollars toward the schools to
bring them up to where we want the
performance of the schools and students
to be so I think there's some larger
questions here obviously about systems
but there's there's far more data that
we collect and publish and put out there
than I think is just what's included on
well I I I get that too you know I just
when I called the summer okay on asking
you how many kids uh have IEPs requiring
more than 80 percent of the time less
than 80 percent of Time how many are in
uh Hospital situations or you know
residential placements and you had that
information for me very very quickly
um so I I understand that I however I
I'm conflicted in this right here from
the standpoint I feel that this
information's important that we get this
from our schools from a state
perspective there's some state issues
here which I'm sure may not be Federal
issues
um for example when we want to know how
many uh schools had their Emergency
Management plans in right and we found
out 20 percent
um
um then we had a hammer on them we got a
little bit more when we had the teacher
uh shortage committee here wanting to
know how many superintendents have
forwarded their numbers in and and Steve
says yeah maybe 46 I got as high as 56
the other day he said so I I know you
have to chase people to get this
information I know you are are
overwhelmed with it but I I'm just a
little contrary to trying to not include
yeah yeah
and and Rick I think it it raises a um
you know you know based on you know some
of the some of the comments that Nate
and Caitlin have made
um you know erases the question you know
when we when we take a look at this and
what sort of data that we want to be
collecting for for State purposes
um uh you know is is this the list here
is this the exhaustive list are there
other things Nate said you know they
collect this is probably a tip of the
iceberg obviously from the the data you
collect on the doe 25 is so we're not
even touching Financial right we're not
even touching this is all this is
student outcome data and
and yeah and and
um and so there may be there but
plan it's just not demonstrated here
within the state law so it's kind of a
we should put all of the information in
the state law so we can do a
comprehensive or we should all learn not
in sort of situation
that's something to consider yeah
but we're not saying get eliminate while
we eliminate no so let's put the rest in
it though and we're not we're not coming
forward and saying hey we want to add
more of these indicators in here when I
met with this uh the commissioner when
we did this back well 2000 whatever 21
20 we've done it so often
um he and I sat down and we we could
drop a list of 25 just like that
um and we put in what we thought was
necessary concurrent dual enrollment and
some of the other things that really you
know give us information which was
usable and good information we know knew
we'd need it when we're designing
budgets when we're chasing the
additional dollars and that does help us
that helped us when we were able to
obtain the extra
3.25 million dollars
this year for each year the buying in
for a concurrent dual enrollment from
1.5 I think it was
that's but without that information
then we're going to have Finance certain
around us to say what do you you know
show us why you need it well we have the
number of kids we can show why and I
just want to be clear we're not
proposing that we wouldn't continue to
collect that information we we would
continue to collect that information
are there any things in here which are
not federally required yes no those all
some of these were state oriented they
didn't ask for FAFSA information do they
that so it's our federal plan that's
approved by the Fed so we as the state
have the authority to do that so what we
did was we took the information from our
plan that's approved by the feds and put
that into state law
do you have to put all these in the
federal plan we didn't have them in the
estate plan right here
so
but don't we only because we allow it to
be the same because we're pumping this
stuff in
yeah yeah because we put it there
but don't we put it in the Essa plan
Ting ones and the federal government and
said
you know this is what we want to do no
the federal the federal plan came first
and then we put it in the state plan so
what we did was a whole different p-bas
system that was in state law in 2017. if
you have an old law book in that room
over there I'd go grab it because it
might be helpful
um in this conversation
um but there was a whole different p-bas
system that was in place and then in
that time we said you know what let's
not have two different accountability
systems with the same assessments of the
same kids one of and then two separate
lists of which schools are not
um are are not providing an adequate
education or a bottom five percent of
schools so that's when we went in and
tied the two together but the federal
the clinical plan came first and then
sort of like my teacher in the law class
where we were just taught the federal
government makes rights all this stuff
and the state just says okay put it in
state law that's what we did in this
situation yes
you didn't have to put all this you
didn't have to put the number of New
Hampshire scholars in
did you
we didn't have to put any of those in so
we as a state came up with College and
Career Readiness indicators because we
needed another so you're required to
have different different indicators
are equity yeah so we were required to
have an equity indicator in the federal
plan and we as a state chose to have
College and Career Readiness indicators
is this right
and um and so our College of career
Readiness indicators are what we
established and we listed those all out
um and that's what the plan is and then
we put that in the plan with a list of
stakeholders we came up with that list
and asked for approval from the
Department of Education from the U.S
Department of Education in our plan to
we need to put a big question mark on
this page
and pursue discussion on this or try to
really think this thing out a little bit
I don't think we're going to be too much
we have to go to court tomorrow so
yeah
good luck
okay so so we we're done for today 266
was the last thing we went through that
first part and we got that cleaned up or
not cleaned up but we know what we have
to do and this last part we have to give
a lot of thought to that so um we won't
be meeting next week other than the one
what day do we have Tuesday
and some places I know that spring break
and then up north most of the state most
of the state of school vacation week
next week next week so we have nothing
else scheduled for next week other than
two
but the following week we will have and
we'll pick this up can so can I just ask
for clarification so where what do you
need from the Department for Earth from
us at this time because I'm not sure
like I know we have a couple areas that
we said we would make Corrections and
whatnot but did you get all this
Corrections from the first several pages
that we've discussed I mean I took notes
but I haven't done anything with them
yet I don't and I don't even know what
the process for doing that is I'm just
kind of waiting until we had waited
through all this and but yeah we don't
have all those answers yet we have to
have this bill out what's the date we
of uh May notice
last day to report all remaining Senate
bills because this is not going to a
right for me
well
your why is making one Amendment
266 rather than that multiple right
amendments
so I I guess what we'll do is meet after
this next week I'll set a date then
let's see we're going in are we into uh
next month yeah we the Thursday will be
a session day I'm sure because there's
no session days this month
there will be in May okay so most likely
we'll have something where we meet on
either that Tuesday or that Wednesday
what are you tied up with Finance with
the Senate I mean we will be but it's I
mean indeterminable I think at this
point we have our we have one
Presentation tomorrow and one we have a
capital presentation I think May 5th or
something like that
but well what what I'll do is I'll talk
with you Caitlyn and find out I'll I'll
try to identify the dates we don't have
anything scheduled and let you know
those dates and you let let me know
which is a good date for you okay
yeah I mean and I think you know as much
of this as we can get done I think will
help the department
um and I think we can figure out where
we can compromise and where we might be
some areas that we may not be but we can
get a lot done that we could move on
yeah and I think I think of the areas
that you're it seems like the areas that
you guys have the most concern of don't
actually affect the department it was
more kind of overall the I think we'll
be okay I think I think the the majority
of the housekeeping stuff it seemed like
we all had concurrence on and that's
actually what we need to be able to
really implement the system
so
okay so we'll we'll set a time up for
the week after next
okay to get together on two six six
sounds good
I'm talking about the whole committee
unless you don't want to come you know
it'd be more like a work session try to
get this thing squared away a little bit
yeah
I think it would be helpful to know if
you wanted to know where the the current
193 e colon 3 would reside in 266 where
where would that be because E3 has been
taken over money yeah we can point that
out yeah bring that back yeah yeah
if you wanted to leave this all in as is
without making Jake
correct
we have a meeting scheduled for
May 8th
yeah you're right
yeah
I mean if we don't have anything to do
I'm sure there is there's so much so
many committees I'm trying to remember
yeah we were doing 306. that's what that
is doing yeah that's doing the yeah the
education rules
I got my copy from Jen